[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is Jay
Pharoah gosh one of the funniest people
I I so sincerely enjoyed this episode as
you are about to hear one of the best
Impressionists of all time an incredible
yes Ander improviser comedian actor he's
incredible I'm so glad he's here from
SNL from White famous and just from
sounding like anybody you tell him to
sound like I mean you're gonna enjoy
this if you enjoy it one tenth as much
as I enjoyed it
uh and I I was gonna say and I hope you
do I actually hope you enjoy it as much
as I enjoyed it so 10 out of 10 as much
as I enjoyed it a couple things to plug
up top I have my Largo show here in Los
Angeles if you want to come see me do
stand-up I believe the next one is on
October 9th which is a Sunday that's
going to be really fun the one after
that is November 3rd which is going to
be a benefit show for Homeboy Industries
I'm really excited about both of those
always love that weirdos are out so go
to largo-la.com
tickets to both of those I'm also going
on a small tour a small but substantial
like Sea Biscuit uh tour and the tickets
where the first three dates are
available at petehomes.com that's
Toronto Atlantic City New Jersey and
Boston uh I'm also going to be right
after that in Chicago San Francisco
Portland Seattle Atlanta Charlotte and
Washington DC is the final date right
now so go to petehomes.com as tickets
are available they will be added to the
site but hope to see weirdos out it's
going to be so good the title of the
tour is where were we because the whole
tour was interrupted we're finally back
I'm so excited that we're back it's
going to be great to see you guys out
there and to connect again a couple
things to plug if you like this podcast
why not try a peeps pick this is how it
works these are the ABCs of podcasting
baby if you like the show try one of
these products that I actually use and I
actually love like our friends here at
ritual I'm holding it up right here this
is their symbiotic plus this is their
pre and pro and post-biotic this is the
first thing I do every morning is this
is my ritual multivitamin I take my
multivitamin and I take my symbiotic
plus pre-pro and post-biotic because as
you know we talk about on the show a lot
gut health is super important to me it
should be super important to you your
gut is basically like a second brain and
gut health is so so so important so you
got to ask yourself does your probiotic
contain clinically studied strains well
meet one that does ritual symbiotic plus
contains two of the world's most studied
strains with over 350 publications of
human clinical trials I love starting my
day with this knowing that I'm doing my
gut right and part partnering it with my
ritual multivitamin knowing that both of
these are going to have a delayed
release meaning it's not just going to
be wasted in the stomach and burned up
it's gonna break down in the colon which
is where you want these things to break
down because that's where they can be
absorbed and actually used by your body
so it makes the component so clearly
ritual there's science-backed and
research stacked especially when stacked
up against the leading direct to
Consumer and top selling probiotics on
the market three to one clinically
studied prebiotics probiotics and a
postbiotic to support a balanced gut
microbiome one daily mint tea I love
that they have a mint taste capsule for
a simple streamlined gut support and as
I mentioned a delayed release which
helps these things reach the colon not
the stomach the colon which is the ideal
place for probiotics to survive and to
grow designed with moisture controlled
bottle technology to protect the
probiotic strains but what I love about
it is it does not need to be
refrigerated I just got this out of my
cupboard cupboard cupboard symbiotic
plus and ritual are here to celebrate
not hide your insides there's no more
shame in your gut game that's why ritual
is offering weirdos 10 off during your
first three months so busy visit
ritual.com weird to start ritual or to
add symbiotic plus to your subscription
today that's ritual.com weird to do your
stomach right and to show your support
of this show secondly we have Pym choose
this is one of the newer Pete's picks
but I have been using them for over a
year p-ym what does that mean prepare
your mind Pym choose help you manage the
feelings of stress anxiety and overwhelm
for those of you that have been
listening to we made it weird you know I
just had my brain scanned and I have
issues with anxiety highly highly active
the anxiety Center to my brain so I need
all the help we can I can get and most
of us do and it's wonderful to know that
when you're feeling worried or stressed
out or as a Val and I like to say you
have a b in your belly you can just chew
two of these delicious natural Citrus
flavored no sit no sugar added chews and
literally guys is within minutes you
start to feel more centered calm and in
control this is completely honest when I
first tried Pym choose I think Val
brought them home I thought they were
too good to be true I but after I tried
them I I calmed myself down I felt more
centered more at peace I immediately
bought a subscription from my mom and
for my brother because we share that DNA
and I was so happy that anxiety and
stress have a natural non-addictive and
non-psychoactive solution I like taking
it at the start of my day to ease me
into whatever it is I'm doing and I also
take it at the end of the day as a
wonderful way to wind down and relax
away the stress of the day I know so
many of us sometimes turn to our vices
at night a Pym chew will get you into
that wonderful safe good feeling
but without that toxic bad after side
after side that's not a phrase how does
it work Pym Chooser comprise a proven
amino acid complexes and adaptogens that
help support the brain and your body's
ability to organically support your
ability to manage and tolerate stress
anxiety and overwhelm they are
specifically formulated amino acids they
target your neurotransmitters
specifically the Gaba system a naturally
occurring neurotransmitter that helps
the body manage chronic stress by
supplying your body with Gaba l-theanine
and Rhodiola Pym is on a mission to end
the stigma surrounding mental health and
to make a better mood accessible to all
and a percentage of their profits one
percent go towards mental health
non-profits including bring change to
mind is a gentle effect of a natural way
to give your body the nutrition it needs
to fight off stress I am so happy to say
it works so go to
ucanpym.com weird for 15 off Pym mood
shoes and show your support of the show
that's you can pym.com
weird for 15 off and show your support
the show last but not least you know I'm
wearing them
's my perfect jeans as you know I
absolutely hate a hard pan I don't
understand how it's 20 22 times are hard
why are we wearing unforgiving soft
expect hard
[__] pants I'm gonna call them what they
are [__] pants why don't we just start
wearing comfortable soft pants well the
answer is they often don't look good
well enter the perfect gene they are the
best looking the best fitting and the
best feeling pants I have ever owned in
my life I wear them when I do TV tapings
I wear them to fancy premieres they look
great I have them in Black I have them
in blue and I have them in dark blue and
I swear by them I wear them every single
day I don't put them on to record the
ads I'm always just wearing them and
they never wear out I'm telling you guys
I put them to the test forget the fact
that they're stretchy and they're
forgiving that's awesome but how about
the fact that you can wear them every
single day and they don't get holes in
them every pair of jeans I've ever had
starts to develop a hole in the crochet
area the the perfect Jean does not do
that they're the best pants I've ever
owned I would sleep I I have slept in
them if I'm being honest and I would
sleep in them every night if it was
socially acceptable they're made of
Premium M stretch fabric that's two
percent spandex two point five percent
rayon but no one needs to know they look
like designer jeans they feel like PJs
come on everybody this is some serious
[__] I'm talking about and they give you
extra comfort and movement that your man
Parts require these jeans stretch so
you're not saying crushed they're
thereby providing the only true home for
your bone
so high quality maximum durability So
Soft you're gonna forget you're wearing
pants and best of all they're not khakis
[__] your khakis and spare your nuts
wear the perfect Jean for the Perfectly
Imperfect men just 60 bucks when you use
code weirdo at checkout liberate your
lower limbs with the one and only
perfect Gene whether you're working with
lemons or lentils a three leaf clover or
a big old honk an eggplant the perfect
Gene has you covered take a peek at
theperfectgene.nyc that's the perfect
gene.nyc and use code weirdo for 25 off
at checkout and try do your body your
lower half a favor and try the perfect
Gene and show your support of the film I
mean that's a win-win right there baby
all right guys enjoy Jay Pharoah he's
awesome I can't wait for you to hear get
into it are we doing it yeah
[Music]
I was so dope no that was yeah
you get as comfortable as you want okay
cool I can do something like like this
oh wait I don't want to [__] up oh my
Flat's not open but a million hits a
million hits Jay Pharoah Jay Pharoah
does a sex tape
tween fly it's called the tween flight
you ever see a twin I'm just kidding
it's not a thing you can see between the
fly
that sounds very provocative that's how
I like to make the guests feel real
comfortable say yeah you can see your
hunk and dunk oh man that's that's what
that's a that must be dick in German is
that what that is I mean uh meat in
German it's like uh Eskimos have a
million words for snow guys like 30 000
for for hunk and dung okay we we can we
can we talk about how this is the most
this is the most uh off-putting uh label
[__] that what is this it's a
freaking skull and it's melt why is it
melted that's outside of a can of water
like I you don't want to drink this it's
called liquid
why are we drinking what is this what is
this Pete you just sounded a little I
didn't know you did Geron yeah oh I
sounded a little extra I would I can't
do it I can't why would we even it's so
ridiculous to it's liquid death like why
would we drink liquid death that's not
smart to do and then 30 seconds of
Silence
this is the most awkward
[Music]
at this side I just that that's what it
is it is it's the silence every time I
watch him and this is actually a
compliment I go why am I rushing so much
he doesn't mind just being like he said
he knows how to sit in the on the
awkwardness of Silence yeah he's like
the perfect person for that he is and
then he knows that it's pulling the bow
string back and then when he finally
does talk and it's like wow it's just
yeah that's when the punch hits yeah
yeah that's genius man I know wow you
just made me realize how much more
genius Gerard Carmichael has in him
because that's yeah you can name a
special Nathaniel and still have it pop
his his special his name Nathaniel no no
no exactly
that's what I'm saying yeah that's what
I'm saying I have it's like punk bands
that call themselves uh nude girls so
you can't Google them yeah he's like I'm
gonna call my special rathaniel and it's
like you're still gonna come we're all
over here going like party fun time it's
like me with my shirt off holding a hot
dog like laughs a minute and he's like
rathaniel of every award and he deserves
it he's that sounds rathaniel sounds
like a um that sounds like a
conquistador
I'm like a like a Don Quixote kind of on
a horse yes or a horse with a with a
with a long sword yeah ooh sword sorry
sword is it sword or is it sword I liked
the way you said sword but you did say
sword but okay and it was untoward okay
cool it was untoward sword sword yeah
toward with my sword I say swordfish I
don't say swordfish but I guess okay I
guess it is swordfish it is but I mean
you're not wrong okay you talk is is no
that's not no Pete that's not rich
because I I get all because I know I
can't do this because I get on folks
sometimes because some people will say
Massachusetts and I'll be like it's
Massachusetts yeah yeah Massachusetts
like what is Massachusetts though is
that a my mother says it we
Massachusetts she's from she's from
Brooklyn but she's well hopefully she's
not from Massachusetts she's definitely
no one's from Massachusetts because
Massachusetts doesn't exist
it's not a real place it's uh it's like
Narnia it's not real
[Laughter]
oh my God it's not real people I have a
wardrobe that goes to Massachusetts
actually yeah yeah you crawl through the
clothes and they're here where the
Chevron the fairy man take you over as
well oh yeah sure it comes Chevron comes
uh who else is there uh Falcor he's
there Falcon oh good pull yeah we must
be the same similar age if you know the
never-ending story yes dude I used to
yeah what a good time what a good time
to be a stand-up comedian all you had to
say was the never-ending story
90 minutes long 90 minutes long with the
most it ended in 90 minutes are you
serious did it no I just mean like it
whatever the run time is it's not never
ending oh you're stupid okay
I'm sorry bro it's the liquid swordfish
swordfish it's the liquid death okay
it's it's that skull it's [__] with
me that's what's happening I'm sorry oh
yeah sure right yeah never ending but
it's a 90 but it didn't do nothing
that's all you need that's crazy I
remember I saw one of the first stand-up
shows I went to I've told this story
before but I want to see what it makes
you think of I wanted the comedy
Connection in Massachusetts
dude you know who's on the show Bill
Burr oh holy [__]
yeah Bill Barr on the show
wow
babies you know yeah I'd get on abortion
like you know
he goes right to it dude I did a show
with Bill I wasn't at well this it was a
different show at Boston Garden to get
comfortable
shoes you can you absolutely can because
I'm like I gotta get a little you could
you know my shoes my liquid death
it had committed it committed suicide
well it's it's still that's how it comes
back to life yes that's why that skull
is there so it so the devil can bring it
back you think of that arm as your back
okay that's the back okay they come up
that way yeah now we're having a
sleepover there it is there it is there
we go all right yeah there we go I'm so
glad my thighs got smaller Jesus this
would have been horrible man I got some
I got The Rock's legs it's crazy like
what do you mean I got like you have
little chicken legs no no he no no you
do I do now I do I'm like no I'm the
rock like right here and then down here
I'm like uh uh uh Kim Kardashian like
because she's got like the you know the
little small let the lollipop legs with
the with the big with the with the Big
Caboose
okay but chunk of dunk it could be a
butt that sounds like a Haagen-Dazs um
flavor of the chunky donut I have the
chunk of dunk please one for me and one
for Nathaniel yes please what for me one
for with Daniel you got a horse
yeah
he's riding oh man we're on it Pete we
on it what the hell we yo I love you
dude that man I loved seeing you well
that is that what you're gonna say we
needed to talk about yeah well
um I was just I just yeah we could talk
about that but I was just gonna say man
I I freaking just from watching your
stuff I just became such a fan man you
are so [__] funny oh thanks dude I
really appreciate that that's that's uh
delightfully not surprising but I don't
get it a lot not a lot of guests come in
and just go like let me tell you I'm a
fan I'm into it like people go like well
this is a shitty garage
I was going to talk about the cobwebs
but I was but I was you know you know
man you should have seen the cobwebs I
walked through and people aren't here
right now and there was there was one
that almost it sounds like a joke but it
almost caught me you got your Rory
I could just see you soon
you just swing it like freaking Frodo
[Music]
dude is that that was that it yeah I
feel like that was it yeah Smiggle
though Smiggle was one of my uh that was
one of the ones we both do smiggles you
do Smiggle too yeah we're gonna do a
Smiggle off guys I was just gonna say
what can we do a Smiggle off for uh
let's see here hold up hold up hold up
hold up hold up
I want to make it do that
is it is it is it is it moving now will
you do it Katie sorry I just wanted to
swing I'm getting hot and I think it's
all on Jay it's me man
you need this event
[Applause]
if you go like that that's pause Okay
because I'm going like this is [__]
watching too much PornHub
I've seen this move before
me too what's your search words precious
it's just search where it is
Brussels what comes up if you search
Precious on PornHub uh Aragon and
Legolas
is it the push by Sapphire it could be
that direction yeah it could be sort of
like uh BBW yes I I my mind went there
second yeah because I was yeah it went
Gabrielle Sidibe afterwards but but yeah
I like that you went extreme first I was
trying to think I don't think I ever
knew her name she's man she's so sorry I
mean I didn't know her last name you
know her yeah she uh she was uh I
remember she came to SNL back in 2011.
that's right with the cherry spitting
yeah she had the Cherry spinning I
remember the Cherry spinning you
remember the chairs isn't that funny
it's always like that sketches
I'm going to say it it's kind of dumb
but that's what you remember it works it
works it works for the for the situation
she she was uh she was really nice man
she had a lot of of good things to say
she was very complimentary towards me oh
yeah um yeah she I mean of course man I
heard it and I heard it and I still hear
it Bob but the Eddie Murphy com
comparisons and things yeah of course
okay cool I was like oh it's like this
generation I was like yeah we'll we'll
we'll see I'm Different he was 19 when
he got the show I was 22 but whatever
we're a little different that's not a
bad difference no it isn't it isn't but
like but like it's like this people you
you know what [__] it it's not different
it's not that different
it's really not I am what is it for now
yeah no go ahead just like the just with
being able to do the Impressions and the
you know and characters and uh and just
being funny like that yeah and so and
you got it from doing stand-up yeah
absolutely and Charlie Murphy his
brother took me in a road with him for
three years oh really yeah and Charlie
was the only one who would do that dog
like you know there were other comedians
I guess some of them were intimidated I
was I was I had a lot of stage presence
I was just gonna say yeah because Talent
can be scary yeah and if you're gonna
bring someone to open for you you don't
want to bring some how old are you at
this point I was in 19 19. you don't
want to bring like a 19 year old
Charisma bomb nah who's doing perfect
Impressions nah before you yeah I was
just talking to Val about this I was
like I can't play I love chance I can't
play Chance the Rapper as my pre-show
music even though I'd like to because I
can't follow a recording of that much
talent if one more label try to stop me
he's gonna beat them
head in the lobby you know you know
you're skipped up isn't that crazy we
both we both skipped it oh edit it out
we both knew it this is the radio edit
kind of podcast this is man I don't got
a radio edit face yeah yeah definitely
so you do you the nicest it looks like a
radio in it sorry I'm doing snaps on
myself
dude I joked myself too it's fine uh why
are you
like I said I was talking I was trying
to I was talking about my Samoan top
half and uh and these and I didn't know
you had the see I your leg looks
completely normal to me yeah now it does
because but but are you like working on
your legs yeah like a thing I run
because if I don't I'm telling you dude
like this goes full Quest love I love
quests I love you love you but love you
this this goes full Let's Go full roots
does he have Questlove have skinny legs
no no no no no no what I mean is they
get big you funny they get really well I
was picturing you know Shrek has little
baby legs that is so hilarious so this
Humpty Dumpty and uh yeah Humpty Dumpty
is the king well he's not the king the
king's horses and the King's Men could
have to pick them up they had they
couldn't do it they had one job
they have one job they couldn't do it
speaking of a stand-up premise that I
was so jealous of open up that Larry
David we call LDS over here open it up
was all the king's horses and all the
king's men couldn't put Humpty together
again it's like the horses were trapped
with the who's
you're only gonna make it worse
you know he knows he's a horse I'm just
a horse chill out I can only Gallop this
is my first day trying to put this
together I don't know why but yes Jay
that is what a horse would sound like
I'm a horse I'm a [__]
better stop riding me because I'm I'ma
turn one day I might kick you in the
kick it kick in the jaw it's it's Eddie
Murphy
oh we're right to that that's like my
character voice for damn near everything
though I just thought I'd break it to
everybody dude if I could sound like
Eddie Murphy
it makes everything so it's likable it's
funny it's it's like unexpected it's
surprising if your car alarm sounded
like that you'd be you'd be happy as
hell if you had an Eddie Murphy car loan
it'd be dope as hell you just be like
beep beep beep beep [__]
beep
don't you hear me beeping
move [__] hey man you think this
is funny but I'm starting to get hoarse
I'm telling you to get out of the way
politely don't you hear the inflections
in my voice how nice I'm saying this
move [__] oh move [__] get out
the way get out the way [__] get out
the way to move [__] get out the way
get out the way [__] get out the way
he did it just so perfectly I have
nothing to add that's right beat home
hey hey move you better move that damn
Tesla did you ever do it for Eddie I
didn't do it in front of him but he was
uh he was aware of it he was definitely
aware of it but he the way that he he
says it always when he's talking about
it he you know he he gets into his thing
and people ask him about the impression
and he goes
he says um well you know Jay Pharoah
does like buddy love he does like me
doing buddy love he doesn't do me doing
me naturally he just does which is this
which yeah yeah yeah but Impressions
aren't aren't fun unless you turn them
up a little bit right you have to it's
for comedic effect but I would say when
I was younger I probably played more to
the character than I did the actual one
and then I when I got a little older I
dialed into it just a little more yeah
just like it's just the same thing with
Trump you do a trump too no I did your
drums I've told Val when I got home like
my report of Montreal was like my hotel
room had an adjoining room with another
comedian and I could hear him like
sneeze I don't care I thought she was
about to say him [__] I was like oh that
would have been oh mortifying damn
terrible
I can't really think of anything worse
you heard more [__] that's crazy
this is painful
I should have never ordered for the back
page I know people I'm the [__] bird
in case the people that can hear him
cheating on his wife apparently he
screams out I'm Bill birth not a good
technique no but it is my
wife and the other thing I reported was
how good your Trump is I you know I
don't even think people know yeah
because it's not one that I it's not one
that I like I I mastered until I really
started paying because I wasn't a fan I
mean you know it's hard to watch yeah
I'm like man auntie look he's absolutely
these people these people absolutely
love me they really do they love me
absolutely Pete you have to understand
something people people listen have
something that's gonna make the American
people this much better it's a bigly
thing it's really big it's huge
not only is it huge it's stretchy not
only is it stretchy but it's humongous
it's all of those things put together in
one pot of Gumbo that's it the American
God Bless America God Bless America
bring me boxes I want to grab them you
all called them boxes I call them
[__]
that's what I do I call them buses spell
it b u z z y [__]
[__]
because I'm puzzled everybody doesn't
want to give me the [__] I don't
understand it
you can't find a more perfect I'll kiss
with my grab of my [__] come here oh
it's like he's got a hot meatball in his
mouth and he's trying to cool it the
[__] off and it's never yes you know
what I mean
she's always blowing it the [__] off I'm
like yo what the I'm like yo drink some
water dog you know beautiful beautiful
impression beautiful I couldn't
absolutely you actually sound like if
you close your nose how do you do that
you gotta you gotta do it you got it
it's just about it's about listen listen
listen listen
it's just about totally paying attention
paying attention totally and
everything the way breathes
those little pauses he takes the way
that he puts his hands on the podium
he's feeling the podium even the podium
doing all this damn touching
[__] hey six feet [__] still
monkey pox is out here it goes for
podiums too yeah he goes for podiums and
[__] that's what his two peas he's
I never say that word that much but I
used it in context mother don't be mad
at me she's gonna watch will she she
watches everything I do I I find that so
sweet yeah I do what is it I find it's
stressful huh
what's your mom well we don't we could
just say hi Jay's Bob yeah yeah well oh
no well she's no she's got an old
Instagram page she takes a lot of
selfies um it's Mony her name is uh
Ramona that's her name okay my dad's
name is Antonio and they are not Spanish
at all there's nothing Spanish about
them we eat Spanish food but there's
nothing Spanish about these guys no
actually I am actually Panamanian
that's how you laugh in Spanish if you
didn't know it's just j-a-j I also just
don't like that you said I know you said
black yeah saying you're dead and you
know my dad is I said my I said my
mother's from Panama my dad is from
black it's a joke from black and that is
from black my dad is from Black
it's from a black place let me ask you
this because I I really my thing with
presidents is absolutely absolutely keep
on absolutely let's go back into it
absolutely let me straighten myself
recompose myself I love it baby Holmes
is the greatest
he's the best Pete ever he's the best
breed ever okay VH1's best pit ever H1
H1 better than B Davis in 20 times
better than Pete Davis
Pete Davidson I love him you know he's
he's smashing billionaire vagina he is
oh billionaires didn't they break up
yeah they did I don't know anything and
I know that they broke up I found out
that before I found out the queen died
yeah because I'm not on social so I have
to get my
that's my facts from the world right
Davidson and Kim Kardashian because they
always thought it was doomed and
whatever he's he's such a sweet dude man
have you ever met him yeah he did this
podcast because like way before he was
huge yeah because I saw him at the
Improv
and I was literally like what is
happening right now like I just thought
it was the funniest he had that thing
where he was in high school I'm pretty
sure he was in high school yeah but he
was talking about being in high school
the way you or I would talk about being
in high school like with the perspective
of us like he's been there yeah like he
was looking he was doing it middle age
perspective and he was looking back on
it yeah but while he was doing it yeah
like you know high school it's just like
a place where uh you know you go to to
[__] people and you're pretty much
waiting for like prom and uh if you
don't get [__] prom nights like you're
such a loser I mean I
I didn't [__] anybody darn prom I didn't
my mom gave me condoms my first time
because and I thought like I had
something like I
uh hey hey Pete man met him a few times
and then I met him
brief I saw him briefly after he broke
up with Ariana oh Ariana yes Ariana
Grande Ariana Grande and I felt awkward
and I think I said something like he
said something about that they broke up
and I was like did you guys break up I
think I thought that was funny at least
you didn't say nice dick because that's
what she said really yeah yeah nice dick
she was like yeah we're not together
anymore but nice dick and then that's it
and then wait is that really started she
said on the yeah that whole thing
started she was she was spreading rumors
she spread if she spreads rumors like
that I was like damn I need to find her
because I'm in I'm out here too like
I mean that was her way of being mean
was saying that I guess it was like a
yeah like uh whatever I thought yeah we
[__] type [__] I don't know but they
he was I like I said he's such a he's
such a sweet dude yeah he backed it off
uh but really he no no he's a [__]
he's the Peter's the best man and he's I
mean to have to have dealt with
the things that he has to deal with on a
daily basis yeah well of course the
memory of his pops I'm sure time dulls
everything but that's still dog yes your
dad you know it's always going to be
like a fresh cut you know you got and
I'm not trying to be funny like when
it's on such a a national it's a holiday
basically and it's a tragedy obviously
and so like my Apple TV knows it's 9 11
and recommends like do you want to
remember 911 like YouTube reminds you
it's 9 11 like bumper stick I'm saying
like every time you see it it's not just
like a concept right something that
happened to you that's got to be really
difficult I thought you were going for
like yeah then Pete's special pops up
yeah I thought she was about to say his
specials
day I was waiting for it I was like no
don't say it no leave no no I didn't
okay I didn't okay but yeah yeah so he's
constant he's always reminded of it yes
um and uh also he's got he's got Crohn's
of course yeah I know that and then uh
he's got another uh his perk borderline
personality thing he was talking about
and something else he has a bde a bde
EBS that is that is that is a big
sickness to happen yeah the big energy
is just to just big dick huge dick
energy huge dick David this has the
biggest difference that's why he's the
best that's why you're the best beat but
he's it he's he's the second he's the
second he's the runner up Pete okay dude
you Google sometimes I have to Google my
name to get a photo this is real it
sounds like I'm just Googling myself but
I'll send someone
I just do it so [__] it
I don't oh but no I'm not leaving you
out to dry you should it's therapeutic
it's very therapeutic but go Google
yourself to Google yourself why very
just you like it [__] people what are
they talking about now oh what the [__]
are they talking about well I'll tell
you what they're talking about if you
Google me Pete Davidson comes up why
they're like clearly you meant this one
right
you don't want The Walking radio edit
Google this snaps on me too come on
Google dude you yeah you come up you see
you type do you really type your first
name and the first thing to come no no
you search Pete Holmes in return and
your [__] in his and his stuff coming
are you [__] kidding me that's how
that's how big that's like Googling
McDonald's and Burger King
yo is
his his dick has made the best decisions
oh my
Almighty climbed the climbed the
Hollywood ladder so quick by just
[__] and being talented that's crazy
just [__] that's all he's like the
only fans model he [__] he went to
the top five I got it from the bottom
and then and now we're here he [__]
the top
[Laughter]
okay what I was gonna say what was your
relationship with your parents your your
online yeah nothing on the Pharaoh oh no
there's no very hard to find good
Pharaoh stuff yeah tell me about your
family start there uh uh my family I
gotta do it as Trump I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding absolutely my family my
people or you can you can do it as Joe
Biden man my people my people are
beautiful absolutely beautiful my mother
Ramona Farrell she's from Brooklyn my
father Antonio Farrell he's from Norfolk
Virginia
part of the government and come on man
come on man got a sister your face it's
the face your face
anybody listening to this just audio
look up the face if he he does this [__]
he goes like this with his jaw I'm like
yo I know a Molly Joy when I say
I know what you're doing in there that
Trump was on snorting Adderall Biden's
done rolling on Molly which explains why
he's so gentle eating ice cream all the
time he's kind of wants some good love
I mean this is just it's just burning
man for both of them 24 7. I mean that's
what it is who's gonna get you in
trouble yeah so you're from Brooklyn no
I'm from Virginia oh I'm sorry I'm from
there from Virginia my dad is from
Norfolk Virginia and my mother is from
bed stop Brooklyn and so she moved to
Virginia yeah my father got a
um knocked it up and said all right with
you no not with my sister with your
sister my sister is uh five years older
than me so they were dating in Brooklyn
or in Virginia they were dating in
Brooklyn my dad went to move to New York
for her and then he moved back down here
with her uh back to Virginia with her so
once they had kids uh once once yeah
once my sister came was it because it's
hard to raise a kid in the city probably
yeah they probably wanted more uh they
wanted more space and you know uh kind
of moving into the uh suburb life you
know what I mean which which eventually
did happen I mean that first week at
first it was like townhouses which now
they own freaking crazy yeah really Yeah
man they got a whole bunch of real
estate and [__] they're they're rolling
in the real estate yeah Dale Rose in the
Deep they roll into real estate okay
yeah man I got to get on that truck I'm
gonna get on that train too that's what
my dad did too it's how he's he's not
from Bed Stuy but like he's from Winter
Hill like the Somerville area and he
really didn't sort of have a similar I
hate calling it make good like you're
making bad if you're still in Somerville
but like he made money let's say let's
call it what it is he made money but but
it was by investing in real estate young
and everybody like it's funny like it's
always move it always seems to be moving
up so like now there's some area of New
York or otherwise that is incredibly
cheap that we just can't see where it's
going to be in 20 years or whatever it
might be that's what my dad did that's
what your parents said we should we hey
Pete we're just trying to find it
together with that next box two idiots
yeah I'm just saying
there's not a lot of roses over here we
just bought swamp land in Florida this
is gonna be huge it's gonna be
absolutely huge
crocodiles are gonna love it they
absolutely are I'm gonna make nuggets
build a Papados back here get the black
people the African-American share that
they love Papados they really love it
it's the best thing ever when I was in
Vegas I said do people stay at the Trump
uh hotel and they said not really and I
said why he said No gambling license oh
there's no Casino in the Trump Hotel
because you know how cocky of a
[__] he's gonna hide he's gonna
compete people go there together it's
just they'll come here for the
atmosphere and the experience it's it's
got my name on it it's already
automatically better automatically
better than everything that you've seen
No gambling because if you ever went
bankrupt you can't have a Gambling
License in Las Vegas that's [__] he's
such a [__] such a businessman yeah
he's such a [__] business just like
him burying uh the uh that's so [__]
up wait what it buried his wife on the
golf course
buried his wife from the golf course to
get a voice so he get a tax break he saw
he can get a tax break I didn't know
that he buried his ex-wife on his golf
course so he could get a tax break by
declaring it a a a a cemetery you shut
your mouth when you dead ass
yeah I felt bad saying that but I'm just
shocked you sh you shut your mouth when
you're talking to me that's just what
came out I'm just so aghast yeah it's
yeah that dude he he's hard he has no
the heart is not there and then yeah
okay it doesn't care doesn't care two
[__] okay go ahead what were your
parents like did they were they yeah
still together been together for 41
years really so that's why I know it's
possible man I know I know it's possible
and wait you admire their relationship
yeah like 41 where they're just kind of
right riding it out right now they like
each other they really like each other
now of course they've gone through their
um different um sure phases or whatever
but that's how that's how relations
that's how a marriage is you got to keep
falling in love with the same person
over so many years and you got to keep
remembering why you did it that's right
and they're the perfect example of that
they're in the embodiment of that how'd
they meet
um Church get out yep they both went to
the same church well went to go to to
the same church I still go to that
church we all go to that church really
yeah it's crazy in Virginia it's uh it's
it's one in Virginia it's uh it's one in
Philadelphia Delaware we got them all
over the country is this forgive is it
like a black church is it like it's a
black flavor Apostolic Church Apostolic
yeah okay a lot of uh a lot of clapping
uh talking about talking back yeah like
that's right triple Cloud yeah yeah yeah
praise them triple claps when the music
come on
that's how you know you in a black
church when you see them triple claps
because white folks y'all don't do that
[__] you don't do that you just y'all
just reach for the sky like the Lord we
do like you Goku and you absorbing the
the power of the Spirit Bomb you're
right there is sort of like a solar
panel yeah like we're absorbing yeah
close your eyes yes and we oscillate
like a sprinkler
[Applause]
we're quiet
we're watering the spirit oh you're
watering the spirit
that's [__] hilarious piece and when
the Black preacher would come because
we'd have a a sister Church
sorry we're not done laughing no I'm
sorry I never want to stop Joy oh boy oh
okay go ahead go ahead please this is
the church our sister Church he'd come
and preach here so there'd be a guy from
an uh is are all black churches
Apostolic no no no no no no there are so
many different because they're bad most
of I feel as Baptist there's
um
Presbyterian press Presbyterians yeah
yeah I just want to make sure that
wasn't a term that I should be using
instead of saying black church no no you
can just say black church is fine so he
came from a black church comes to our
very white our church was so white it
was khaki it was like incredibly white
okay and he would preach and he would
stop this really made an impact on me
and if you watch my stand-up you can
tell because if he wasn't getting a
response it'd be like you have to
understand like where I come from people
like respond like I need you would make
my mom be like that's right
then try like the corniest most pretty
uptight white people and he'd get you
get them he gave y'all he gave y'all
Church swag he did gave y'all churches
he gave us a pass really well at a
certain point you're really just you
know you've been doing it like kind of
stiff and boring so long it's nice to
have someone come and be like it's okay
if I say something you like you can like
you can move do it you can move and the
music forget it I mean I'm not telling
you anything you don't know yeah but
when I would go to that sister church it
was like oh these people really mean it
do you believe that
oh God's Gonna Hold Your Hand you're
like it will be a happy day I have a
theory I gotta I got a theory though I I
think the reason why y'all would y'all
weren't as hat y'all weren't as happy
because yeah because black folks suffer
so much now that's it so we always so we
will always really look forward to the
afterlife more than we did this life
right I agree that's absolutely true uh
who has a bit about that I just saw
someone do a bit
Neil Brennan is like the height of white
privilege oh it's on his new special I
can't I'm gonna watch it I can't say it
hasn't come out yet but he has a bit
that's that's in in line with us that
it's like what is more privileged than
being like no I I like this more than
than Heaven is basically I'm not ruining
the joke Neil
this is my chabelle when I call Neil I
go
that's that's [__] that's good ah
from you Pete that was good yes I could
only say that I'm not being serious when
I tell you that brother that was good as
[__] bro that was good as [__]
triple crap
he homes
yes tell me tell me about that church
tell me about your parents meeting there
oh and what do you know about it I know
that my dad was uh he he was shorter
than he than he was uh when they got
together my mom told him she said if she
said I can't beat with somebody I can't
be with somebody short so you gotta if
you want to be with me you got to grow
he freaking grew three inches I'm so I'm
dead bro I'm not lying I'm dead ass like
he [__] ninja turtle out of the blue
like he just
he Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle son like
he got taller he found the he found the
secret of the youth he found it he grew
that's like a Bible story I guess I got
church on the mind yeah all those
stories in the Bible where it's like you
can date my daughter but you have to
work for me for seven years there's
seven more years there's always a Twist
yeah exactly there's plagues your dad
what did he do go home
yo he had to be like the old boy in the
Snickers commercial that was trying to
grow his head back in the day remember
this [__] oh my God very vaguely he had
like very very his whole top was like
missing and he was he was
[Music]
and he has one hair and he looks he
looks in the mirror he takes somebody to
the Snickers he's like you're gonna be
there a while grab a Snickers and then
Larry he tried to do it again and then
he's like and he came back and he had a
[__] monobrow and [__] it was that
was great I don't know who wrote that
you got to hand it to a good commercial
yeah that was so we're gonna have to
edit that out because we are brought to
you by Milky Way oh oh [__] Milky Way is
there anything better than when they
don't have Snickers are you in a gas
station and they are out of Snickers
grab a Milky Way it's the Snickers but
there's no peanuts question it's extra
nougat it's where all the nougat goes
and what is nougat uh it's like whipped
egg whites right is it I think okay then
why doesn't it go bad yeah why does it
stay like that and why doesn't the milk
and milk chocolate not go bad
that's because is it almond milk that
they use in that I mean I mean almond
milk never good yeah
almond milk never goes bad even when it
expires you ever notice that is that
true I mean it for me
[Laughter]
any of the alt milks yeah I mean it's
not all right milk so I don't drink the
alt-right milks where they're like we're
white they're white We're white
I'll dried milk
from proud cows I gotta go I gotta go
this riff is uh not worth it no I love
it I [__] love it I don't bail so
your dad yeah Joshua uh Joseph style
yeah grew three extra inches three extra
inches for your mom is she a taller
woman or she just wanted she's five six
she just wanted somebody women like they
that's you know and you're told yeah I'm
six too that's and I don't know how the
hell I came into existence oh yeah yeah
Daddy Dad is 510 and Mom is five six so
he should be five seven if it weren't
for a miracle from the Lord the Lord
said hey you gotta uh you got a pharaoh
to make
that is incredible Yeah man so they met
at church met a church didn't they right
away he gained three inches and then
does she tell a story of like noticing
and then your father walked in and I
swear he was three inches taller he he
was he's right there with her like yeah
I grew like he's just like it happened
yeah I agree I never I'm dead ass I've
been more glad that I asked I'm never on
the show asked somebody how their
parents met I've never been more glad
but I'm gonna tell you something I'm
gonna tell you something crazy about me
like well that sounds so narcissistic
you're in a safe space we're here to
talk about you okay cool cool all right
so I grew three inches after I graduated
high school and I was 17. when a growing
is supposed to be done yeah and this is
the Pharaoh three I know yeah it's the
Pharaoh three you got the Pharaoh three
and then your dad Bobs and goes how old
was he when he grew the Pharaoh three he
was 17. Pharaoh three he was 17 dude
that's crazy you guys have like a little
program in you that waits to you want to
know something else about us we have six
fingers
that was my accident she was like yo no
you are not going my babies are not
going to school they are already it's
already gonna be hard enough
[Music]
so you grew dead ass dead ass bro what
about that ass that ass that's what
that's that's what I'm just saying I'm
serious I'm dead ass
dead ass you're saying dad ass nah nah
man
is that is that is that is that called a
rim job is that what it is a rim job
yeah that's I was gonna I was gonna use
that term yeah I wasn't I wasn't
describing rim job rim job and no no it
wasn't the man not that moment you know
maybe 30 minutes ago not now it's uh
yeah before I got here like right before
I got here so you not a dad though like
uh she was Puerto Rican whatever look
look my life is my life okay I didn't
have a Puerto Rican today that was two
months ago um so Pete yeah yeah so so my
mom my my parents yeah we I'll bring it
back to Virginia Virginia you grew up
there I grew up Chesapeake Virginia I
went and how was it dude it was uh I had
a I had a pretty good childhood man like
your parents got along my parents well
as long as much as you would think
married couples would would get along
you know more problems you know they uh
sister sister was somebody I would say
who was protective of me
um I felt like I didn't really get
protected anywhere else
um but what is that my sister because
man I was I was bullied
um I I was I was joked I was I was
awkward why I mean I mean nobody
deserves that and there's no answer that
you could give what if you were like
well I was gangly oh okay that's fair
I'm wondering what was it that made you
outside of the group in school I don't
dude I don't I don't know I was we were
already you know coming from the the
church that we came from man it was uh
the mindset was a little the new bishop
had to come in and like break our
mindset down uh we were we were
following this guy before and everybody
was treating him as if he was the Lord
yeah and he he orchestrated like that so
his son came in and came and was like yo
we're not gonna do it like that you know
it's it's all Jesus it's not I'm gonna
need more on that so there was a be yes
I'm gonna need more on that so one of
the things that kind of made you a
little bit different was that you were
going to this church yeah well-meaning
Earnest people that wanted to worship
God absolutely and then the leader went
a little bit sideways yeah when was what
happened uh he was just he just had
people he had pictures of himself he was
selling people were buying the story in
the book I mean you hear about this all
I just want you to feel comfortable and
safe oh yeah it's fine you hear stories
like this all the time it was a little
cold today yeah yeah it was yeah the sun
saw all of the problems you know he went
and I love him a a Bishop Omega that's
that's my because Omega is the non-cult
one that sounds like a call yes it does
come I'm sorry bow down bow down the
Bishop Omega are we following a
Transformer right now
this is the word of Optimus Prime
Thessalonians Bumblebee
[Laughter]
bumblebee 314. what was that dude doing
and where your folks into it and I'll
I'll show a little bit here I remember
at my church my mom got in a little bit
of not trouble but there was a guy or I
could have been a woman who came and
they were preaching that like every
disease was linked to a sin and of
course like I mean I mean herpes of
course come on like you Jesus
[Music]
like when you're right you're right he
writes hey I'm just I'm just saying
you're right on herpes doc like you
yelled that out from the back of the
church I can attest to this Theory with
herpes
I feel you don't have to yell at every
meeting I just want people to know I
have to I have
I have Dude Perfect Dude Pete that is a
funny that that is that's a sketch man
that's so [__] funny just in the back
so the Reverend is up there preaching
the word of God the dude just gets up in
the back we get lost I can attest to
that like he he's like don't let the
devil take you down the wrong path let
me tell you the wrong path often leads
to Atlantic City New Jersey
I was going to say uh I was going to say
8th Street 8th Avenue but you know
whatever you know what I mean you do
what you want well go ahead but their
theory was that every everything was
came from a sin so like I remember of
course I looked up what jerk jerk
jerking off fled to oh what do I have in
my future that was the uh that was the
start I had the thesaurus and I was like
masturbation and it was I think it was
liver disease and I remember being like
I guess I'm getting Liberty he's like
well it regenerates yeah
that is worth it not an alcoholic I
swear I only jerk off that's right I'm a
jerkaholic but my mom got like she
followed that guy and then the church
decided that that guy wasn't legit and
then I remember my mom being kind of
bummed out because she was getting some
value out of it so I'm wondering what
was your family's attitude towards the
one that was cultish um they at for
everybody it was they were everybody was
brainwashed he was charismatic yeah very
very charismatic uh people uh very I
guess you could say he was uh he was he
was super gregarious so yeah you know
people people levitated to look or they
you know levitation yeah he saw even
when he passed away they were there were
church members who were uh holding the
back of the limousine holding the back
of the hearse as it was go no out like
that like so there were people that
followed him all the way to the end all
the way to the end and some folks I
think a couple people thought he was
going to come back you know from the
dead I was like maybe if he's a van I'm
four I'm like yeah maybe if he's a
vampire yeah what's wrong with y'all I I
would check the castles
the stakes we need snakes
all the steaks please I saw me at Olive
Garden he can't reach us there
um
so people were into him and your family
was sort of into them did it happen
slowly like as soon as it dude he got
named the pastor yeah he was there for
years dude he was there for like
he was a general overseer for what did
Bishop Johnson died six Bishop Johnson
the one before him same type died 69 and
then uh
Bishop Bishop Omega was 1991 so that's
about yeah so oh boy so uh blessing us
he was in power for like like 22 22
years whoa yeah and was it not to say
nutso but was it kind of off the rails
the whole time it was it was slowly it
was it was off the it was off the I was
I was young I was a I was a baby I was
born in 87. so I don't remember a lot of
the things that were happening but I
remember I do get told the stories and
um there was a couple of things I
remember just but not all of the Antics
and things man I was such a baby so my
parents were what were the stories
um
oh man Pete I'm gonna get a call from
[__] Jay but you said the new guy's got
Omega Supreme Omega amazing Omega
Supreme we're gonna fill that
congregation that sounds like yes you
can get new people that sounds like a
Yu-gi-oh character
Omega Supreme or Mega shinron this is
Dragon Ball is this is what's happening
here
um uh okay so some of the stories that
were told what did he do uh there have
to be good stories oh my gosh she made
oh yes
nobody could leave the church for a week
I think nobody was showered he was he
kept everybody at church everybody at
church they didn't shower of course they
had a couple of bathroom breaks I guess
people I guess when he would go to the I
think when he went to the bathroom
people would run out and use them real
quick and try to get back before he came
back and he would be he'd pick out who
left like he would he'd be on that he
was on that start you left yeah you you
was yeah you left too man Chris
Tuckerman you left too man
[__] want everybody to stay here with
you
I'm stinging
wait can you give me some help was this
a retreat or was it just a Sunday that
went this long we went to the next
Sunday yes it was a church I think it
was a church convention we have church
conventions you know what I mean we have
international national the youth
conference the little flock convention
we'll have all these different uh Church
conferences
um so he would I think it was I I don't
know if it was the youth conference it
was one of the long ones the youth
conference used to be a week I don't
know how long it is now it's like four
days or whatever because
um our Bishop he's getting older he's
like all right go home you know we can
do this in four yes we could have done
this over Zoom yeah he like he's a
sports fan he likes watching he likes
getting out so he can see the games
that's what you're right that's all
right
all right God is good all the time all
right let's wrap it up that's how he
sounds he's got that deep just deep this
is preaching on a Sunday and didn't stop
it didn't stop until the net until a
week later all night too yes
he would preach all night or he would
have I think he would take a break and
he would have another he would have like
uh and that's when the Lord yeah he's at
it like another guy he's back there he's
back there chilling he's back there
chilling and drinking wine and
everybody's in the front uh stinking and
clapping that triple clapping
and but if I'm hearing correctly afraid
to leave afraid of him yes yeah he
struck fear into these folks and was
there like discipline sort of stuff like
would you be outcast or exiled from the
church oh yeah they would yeah they
definitely they Exile you and they call
you a reprobate that's what you yeah oh
my gosh yep and you don't want to get
labeled as a reprobate because then you
know you come back to you come back to
the church and uh the church members
could could kick your ass yeah of course
yeah I know like like really oh I'm
sorry yeah not a figure of speech no no
they would really yeah you would you
could really get attacked yeah there
have been I I remember my uncle my uncle
threw one of the church members out of
the church uh really he literally yeah
like yeah yeah straight up like ah yeah
we both said like jazz
um we think a lot we think yeah and
you're 10 years younger than me I'm
putting it together it's crazy but we
still have the same references Ninja
Turtles Jazz I'm an old soul man why
older so not an old soul you're not old
I know what you mean why more than
Charisma what was he doing were there
like stories was he healing people was
he like did he have prophecy he was
would it we had a
the
the overseer before had like this rule
book that he created and his son his son
the the one that I was just talking
about yeah he kind of trans is
translated it over and then controlled
everybody what these what's these Book
of Rules started it his dad wrote a book
rules his dad had a book of rules and
then uh and then he just continued it
and with the the rules I have to imagine
were pretty strict yes like you can't
like cotton style like women can only
wear cotton stockings and the dresses
were like uh what was it like was they
had to be like like 12 was it 12 inches
or eight inches from the ground or
something like that okay uh men had to
men had to wear uh had to wear suits and
uh just simple stuff and if you didn't
do all of this you would go to hell
yeah we had our own Catholic regime
happening it was crazy we had our own
set of rules that we were and did you
grow up in that fear that you were going
to get kicked into the furnace no not me
I mean well hell of course the fear of
hell has always been put into into my
mind and I I mean even the dreams I have
dreamed some crazy [__] because of it
but really yeah yeah oh my god really
when you were little when I was little
there used to be petrified of Hell of
course
um but it's a weird thing when grown-ups
are like yeah I know we tell you a lot
of stuff yeah but that's this is real oh
yeah all I knew was church though like
that's what I all I knew was church
that's that was what we would travel
every weekend to go to some different
place like I pretty much practically
lived in New York and Philadelphia
because we will always go back over
there our headquarters was in
Philadelphia
um another one of the main churches in
New York and that's you know all the
northern folks that's all of my families
up there so I would basically
but Bishop Omega kind of like I said he
took that rule book and was like he's
the one that looked and said yo none of
this stuff is going to put you in hell
the only thing that could put you in
hell is if you disobey the rules in this
book which is the Bible so he was like
yo straight out the book and he had to
train retrain everybody to get straight
out of the brook and people got it
together they know and the folks that
were seriously brainwashed there you
know a lot of them passed away yeah you
know so after they held on to the hearse
after they held on to the hearse yep I
don't give a [__] who it is I'm not
holding on in the back of no damn car
[__] that no my my shoes and damn near
um no those are nice yeah I'm not good
my Jordans get the [__] out of here get
out of here really what the [__] I look
like running in some Android and we're
gonna go uh hold on to the back of the
hearse what shoes are you guys wearing
hey I know I can't do it I got Saint
laurent's one I can't do it I can't for
when you're doing some weird Church
holding chips
um okay so you grew up and we'll get to
God and all that stuff but did you start
performing in the church yeah I mean I
was joking
I was joking to church members I was
impersonating the church members I was
making jokes I would everything I would
see uh yo I saw crackheads I didn't know
they were crackheads in my church I
didn't know that they were crackheads
well in Norfolk you know the place I was
in Norfolk there was the street Liberty
Street it was a lot of them walking down
so some of our members were uh you know
uh uh or had drug addiction so uh like
this one says the rest in peace to her
but she would come in church and she
would she did how y'all doing God is
good
and she go like this yeah and as a
little kid I'll let her know what is
going on here yes yo what the [__] so
every time I would see it I'd be like
you're actually making me remember like
when you're a kid and you're you know
comedically inclined but you don't know
what you're out of bounds I used to you
know probably do impressions of people
that couldn't help but act that way yeah
but you don't know you don't you don't
know it's still it's still funny as [__]
you know it killed if I'm being honest
people loved it I'm just kidding
um but I like you there's and I'd love
to hear your thoughts on this church was
like safe you know people were not
always nice but like for the most part
nice welcoming accepting and it's a
community so that's where I I this is
how long ago it was I would do Bill
Cosby Impressions on stage and and it
would murder people absolutely loved it
and then when I got to college I went to
a Christian College I would do
Impressions here you went to a Christian
College yeah yeah oh man two liquid
deaths okay two LD is
um I would do Impressions I remember was
Professor Barkley at Gordon College and
this is something I actually said once
you and this is how he talked to he's
like I uh I find it very helpful to uh
you make sure that my wife and I uh make
love at least uh once a week
uh you know that could be hard so we
would pick a day
and I swear he almost told us today he
was like so we decided that every
you know a certain day I was like we
almost were able to track why he's
happier on Monday oh yeah
right yes Sunday he was getting it yeah
as for an extension on your paper on
Monday because Barkley got laid was it
so what does he do he's going to church
to go they pray they go to church go to
Golden Corral and go home and [__]
that's what they did they did yeah and
you know what
what
like is that what you do now Val and I
with the four-year-old now we we have to
schedule we don't schedule it but like
you have to make sure you do it yeah
this is what I say it's like writing I
go like if you sort of feel like it or
you're tired you got to go with it
because sometimes sort of feel like it
is as good as you knit and then with me
every time I have sex as soon as I'm
doing it I go like oh yeah I love this
I can't hold on to it and if I'm tired
and our baby like was up all night or
whatever it is and I'm in bed I'm just
like hey and I'm like have sex and I'm
like get the [__] out of here you know
like you just want to sleep yeah but
then as soon as we start having sex I'm
like why was I resisting this honestly
this is going to sound weird but it's
the same with meditation it can be hard
for me to meditate then almost every
time I do I'm like why didn't I want to
do this yeah take a [__] break but
your brain is so persuasive it being
like you don't need to do that yep it's
like Joe Pesci up there he's like
it doesn't make any sense go do
something drink some coffee or respond
to some emails yeah and then you
meditate that's why I like calling
meditation snuggling with infinity it's
a better way of putting it that is so
good you're just like
it's so much better than like
that's absolutely one of the best
um descriptions I've ever heard in my
life like dude that's [__] great
Robert Downey Jr
gotta be good I didn't say it I didn't
even say it dude it's just the way you
just [__] explain that bro it's just
totally just [__] ridiculous just the
way you just said that [__] off I've
never dude ever put it like that before
it's so [__] great feeling something
that had to be expressed as Robert
Downey Jr that's what I watched yes I
like that so much
here's Robert Downey Jr it's because
it's like it was
like it's it's one of those things where
you know everybody's just you know
talking [__] all the [__] time
dude and you just [__] wow just wow
I've never heard it put like that before
it's just absolutely amazing and who the
[__] am I I'm just a billionaire
philanthropist and also just uh you know
somebody who saved a Marvel series and
whatever you're welcome you're welcome
yeah
laughs
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by raycon
wireless earbuds something that I just
discovered and I have been loving them
I've been listening to a lot of
audiobooks sitting in the old backyard
I've been listening to tribe for those
of you that have been hearing me quote
that book so much and I've been
listening to tons and tons of music and
it's been great one of the reasons it's
been great is because I listened to all
this stuff on my raycon raycon wireless
earbuds raycon's everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever with
optimized gel tips I love the gel the
Jill tips for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and
they will not budge trust me I wear them
on my treadmill I like to walk I do
sometimes run either way I sometimes run
either way these earbuds are staying in
place plus raycon gives you eight hours
of play time and a 32 hour battery life
I never have to worry if they are
charged raycons are also priced just
right you get quality audio at half the
price of other premium audio Brands
which I'm really happy to share with you
guys it's no wonder raycon's everyday
earbuds have over 50
000 five-star reviews they have uh three
customizable sound profiles earbud tap
functions noise isolation they are truly
truly incredible I love putting them in
knowing that they're going to stay
placed stay in place knowing that
they're not going to make my ears sore
because I often wear them for hours on
end they stay in they stay comfortable
they look great and on top of all of
that they are affordable so go to buy
raycon
r-a-ycon by raycon.com today and use
code weirdo 15 to get 15 off your raycon
order that's code weirdo15 at by Ray
on.com to score 15 off by raycon.com
code weirdo 15. all right let's get back
to it
wait can I bring
go back is the story I met him and it
was so I love that man yeah he's great
he's I I I saw him and I was like yo I
can't and he starts
he starts like kind of mimicking me and
then he did an impression of you he was
like he said oh I can't believe it and
he just walked off and I was like dude I
it kind of hurt my feelings kind of hurt
my feelings because I was like he sort
of defused the situation by just kind of
mimicking you and then he didn't even
didn't walk it away yeah it just I said
wow I wow I always I've quoted this a
million times because it really changed
the way I think about famous people is
Mulaney said that Mick Jagger when he
was on SNL Mick Jagger was there he said
make sure everyone's heard this a
million times but here it's almost over
Mick Jagger talks to people like we
talked to Siri yeah because Diet Coke
like he just does that
Diet Coke and mullaney said to me it
changed my perception he goes are you
polite to Alexa and I'm like oh and when
Robert Robert Downey Jr sounds like here
comes another Alexa and he's like you
know what I'm gonna do something weird
yeah I gotta do something weird because
this guy is totally gonna freak out bro
he's gonna he's he's definitely just
gonna but you were on the cast I know I
know and that's why I heard but I was
like dude I really like tell me yeah go
ahead yeah who who blew you away with
how nice they were let's give a good one
with how nice they were yeah uh other
than Gabrielle Drake Drake but of course
you he's oh yeah he's from Canadian bro
Canada bro like of course bro like he's
gonna be like so [__] nice but he was
like bro like he flew me and my [__]
friends out to [__] um like London
bro like it wasn't like no it was um it
wasn't it was Birmingham bro it was
Birmingham yeah he he flew he flew me
and my friends we were in London he flew
us out the Birmingham
um he gave us our own [__] bus he put
women in there like Drake is [__]
great yeah yeah this happened in 2014.
yeah we were hanging out yeah you ran
into Drake I was in London I ran into I
ran into the Drizzy drink I ran into a
promoter named Leon you know Leon of
course yeah
[Laughter]
I know Leon he's a good guy yeah it
works with Drake
so he ran into Leon ran into Leon um and
it was so it was so crazy because
we just we didn't plan anything we just
go out I said yo I'm not planning
anything it was me and two my other
friends uh my best friend uh Gerard
Tanner was there uh he always and shout
out to him he does his thing called and
then we had sex podcasts and that [__]
is blowing up right now I don't know
I've heard of it no I didn't know that
course okay edit it out okay cool okay
so I'm just kidding and then we had sex
yes and then we had sex with you with
your ready uh Gerard but it's but it's
really it's it's fun but okay so we make
that joke every time whenever someone
promotes something else all right so yes
absolutely I thought you were serious I
was like oh [__] oh God no I saw you
think that I think no no no absolutely
check out and then we had sex podcast
check it out okay so uh with me him and
uh another another uh another another
dude another one of my uh friends his
name's uh Carter we were all out there
and I said dude I'm not planning
anything let's just walk we just walked
down the street ran into this promoted
his promoter was like yo man on the
street on the street on the [__]
Street he goes um
he goes yo dude he said he says where
you guys from he recognizes you he
didn't recognize me he didn't recognize
me but I'm going to tell you but you
were right here hold on hold on no hold
on though so he goes um he goes where
you guys from I was like well you know
like New York Virginia whatever he was
like oh yeah I'm always in New York you
know you know uh DJ who kid that's my
guy and DJ who kid is one of my homeboys
one of my close friends too so I was
like you listen to DJ who kid he was
like yeah he was like you know I love
this dude up there man like the dude
does all these voices man and I was like
Jay Pharoah he was like yeah and I was
like hi he was like oh [__] so he said
yo dude he said come to Circus de Soule
whatever his Club is Drake and Rihanna
there and I know them so he takes he
takes us there we go there Drake is
there Rihanna's there and Rihanna's like
oh my god what the [__] are you doing
here like like is it um SNL like Live
this week like you're supposed to work
like what are you doing I swear yeah I'm
sorry
looks like a cat with a secret
and she talks like Jed Apatow's third
daughter
[Music]
[Laughter]
Brianna love you
um
she sounds like one of the applicant
girls
the Finney Warriors are going to be I'm
just saying that's a very uh almost like
a valley kind of voice which Iris and
mod don't sound that way
I'm sorry it's more like I'm sorry maybe
I did it wrong it's more like the
Barbados Lee She's she talks like
flaming from work
oh yeah we're gonna book you on the show
it's me Rihanna yo oh they're always I
was gonna say they're always after me
lucky gems but we're gonna be better
than that
Rihanna can't she has to talk like this
hey
hey it's me Ariana it's got to be cool
and Sultry and Smoky not what I just did
that sounds like it comes with a with a
scratch face and some and some uh some
puff lips and
basically Little Kim's body
oh yeah I thought that's something I was
like that's wig
Rihanna yes okay keep going yes okay she
says hello Rihanna says hello and Drake
says um he's like bro like he's like
dude like what the [__] you're here bro
like yo like what are you guys doing
tomorrow and I was like we ain't got
nothing planned he's like dude come out
to Birmingham bro like like I got a show
and like you guys can like stay and I
said well we kind of we're staying in
London he was like yo I'll fly you out
it's like what really yeah man I'll fly
you out come on I was like okay so we
just [__] said [__] London and we just
went to Birmingham for a day and chilled
with Drake Rihanna at the [__]
concert oh and this was like when it
started from the bottom that's the start
that's when that's when that hit came
out and that uh which album was that um
nothing was the uh was it was it Nothing
Was the Same is that Nothing Was the
Same you don't know God dang it damn it
oh I'm sorry
down I think it was because it's Take
Care Drake gave you your own bus but I
missed the Drake bus I don't know you
didn't you didn't get on the dress you
were invited your name was on the scene
really that would have been so fun to
write it hey Rihanna
wow started at the bottom now we're here
some [__]
get under my umbrella hello hello hey
I'm thinking about how you used to got
hit your mom hit you with a Ninja
Turtles you saw you wow yeah you dug you
got that yeah that was my favorite was
yellow it had green turtles on it
ruin the show for me I ain't want to
watch it no more after that I was like
[__] ninja turtles having flashbacks oh
God huh Michelangelo
oh hilarious cannot be me you watched it
you watched some of it a clip all right
you saw it somewhere oh yeah no I listen
to your album oh okay cool yeah there we
go yeah there we go uh trust me uh my
[__] my [__] is way better now I'll go
but no you know I will say this about
your album but I felt this way when I
saw you in Montreal we'll get back to
the story we're telling we're actually
telling several stories but on your
record I was like they should be giving
this up more that's all I thought
nothing about you yeah it was actually
the crowd I was like I don't really
understand what's going on it was a
great record but I was like this
deserves an 11 and they're giving it a
seven eight like a regular kind of Club
crowd yes I was like I felt that way
when I saw you in Montreal because that
show was rough like the show we did
together was rough but if you remember
so we did a show together in Montreal
yeah I was sitting in the front it was
The Comedy Awards was it was a comedy
awards so it's like you know it's not
really the crowd's fault it's like 11
A.M in the middle of a festival morning
and then jokes in the morning but you
were going up and I what I think this is
when we became friends yeah I was dying
because I was like and I kept looking at
the crowd being like how am I the best I
have to go up next how am I the best
left but you were thank you undeniably
hilarious and you did great for the for
what it was but it was the same sort of
thing where I was like this should be
getting an 11 right now yeah that's all
that's all I was gonna say so where were
we in the story you we got the culty
thing we got your parents meeting we got
you performing in church I think that
got me joking you got me impersonating
the people in church right you don't
know you're not conscious of what's
really happening right what's going on
that's right the people uh crack people
and we were talking about that in a
correlation to me getting bullied that's
right and that's right thank you yeah we
swapped Mike you're the host now you
just hosted I just you just hosted dude
what was happening in school and it had
to do with you being in the weird culty
Church yeah I you know I think because
of the me just being used to to warmth
yeah you know me being used to folks
being nice and commercial from church I
relate so hard and no one's ever said
that word my church was so sweet and
nice and everybody was so friendly and
accommodating then you go to high school
and I got kids like bumping into me on
purpose and stuff I wasn't like hardcore
bullied by any means yeah but I was like
this is not what I'm used to I'm used to
like hi like friendly ass people like
nice people what happened to you I just
they I I guess I'm just I was they
always call me weird people always just
call me weird they're like yo you're
you're weird uh Ariana yeah
so making the stallion was there too
somehow I don't know even though she was
10 years younger about 10 years younger
maybe eight seven sure I could still
smash
um
people no no it's okay you're you're in
the you're in the Riff bubble okay
you you were being called weird which
now doesn't seem that bad but at the
time it had to be
it was weird it was it was because as a
kid you just wanna wherever you go you
just want to fit in you want to belong
you want to belong and I didn't I'd
never I didn't feel like I belonged I
got I did even the teacher's word even a
teacher Miss Jones she was so mean to me
my first grade teacher my kindergarten
teacher I loved her you know I love my
kindergarten teach you know I got
bullied by this fat kid named Ryan who
pushed me so hard
no yeah and then my dad used to walk me
to the bus stop every day and he saw it
one day because I used to I mean he used
to bully me and I guess this one day he
just pushed me so hard and my dad
watched from the he couldn't he couldn't
go to the uh to the bus stop at this
point and he was like dude I'm running
late he said Jared I'm running late but
I'ma watch you walk down there and make
sure you get on the bus and I'm because
I'm running late trying to get my
clothes on everything so he comes out
he's watching me you know he's doing his
thing he's checking and then Ryan pushes
me and like I fall to the ground skin my
arm you know what I'm saying and he just
ran down the street and he's like yo he
y'all he was it's your dad right now not
bad ran down after this dude and he was
just like yo if you ever touch my son
again I'll kill you like he was like
that and he was and that's very scary
for Ryan because my dad was naked at
this point yeah
he was not full so he was Soulja Boy you
the [__] out he was he was there he was
not nah he had it no he had pants on but
his thing was big was flapping around it
was scary for the guy my dad was packing
you know your dad's thing is always
humongous you know until you get older
and you're just like hey what we're the
same [__]
you might see him taking it they see him
you're like oh wait it's not what I
remember
like I wish I could see my own Ding Dong
from the perspective of me when I was
six
because you're right your Dad that's way
way big freaking huge so your dad's a
huge ass ding dong is flopping around in
his boxers he picks up he doesn't pick
up but in my mind he picked up Little
tubby Ryan yeah you had him he he had
him but he stood up for you he stood off
of me it is a scary story for Ryan I'm
sure he's on a different podcast right
now
he's on a dad he's on a I can't watch B
I can't watch uh I can't watch black.com
uh podcast that's what the [__] he's on
because he's terrorized now you know
black.com you watch it what is black.com
what you don't know about black.com I
know black.gov that's no that's totally
different okay you funny you do know
black doctor I don't know black.com you
really don't what is black.com it's a
it's a site with uh snow bunnies get
smashed by the black community
snow bunnies are white white white woman
yep so it's a porn type yeah it's
pornstar yeah yeah
I go to chubbywhite.com that's oh okay
so that's what you like okay farm girls
that's what you tomorrow
how did they get black.com
Crayola whatever Crayola
have something to say about this
[Laughter]
they got the color.com to be porn so
[__] it's it's a great it's a great site
that's how me and Jamie Foxx bonded I
put overblack.com I had a joke it was
like yo this girl I had a joke I went on
the show and I was like you know what
y'all up tight y'all just need to get
black you know what I mean and what the
one lady was like I was just looking
like that and then Jamie Foxx was like I
know what black.com is Nick
laughs
he writes it under the post yeah I
definitely know what black.com is I know
what black.com is Jay I know what you're
talking about you is I didn't even know
I knew what Jamie Foxx sounded like and
then you do it and I go
Tim that's him have you ever been to a
Jamie Foxx sex party no no I refuse the
answer they make you give on the way out
he makes you rehearse now let's let's
cover if anybody asks if you ever been
if anybody asks you about this you will
never hear all right open robe open bro
because he's drinking from a goblet look
come on here
foreign
you just have to be fully comfortable
once you feel comfortable you have to
worry about anything because you gotta
be fully comfortable first that's all it
is it sounds like real Jamie Foxx yeah
this is you did no no I never went to
that I never would no no no I know but
that sounds like something
yeah
he's got to be comfortable as soon as
you get comfortable you [__] everybody
will be eating out the palm of your
[__] hand is that what he said [__]
that's real [__] listen man you got some
[__] man you got some [__] you need to
use that [__] you know you got that [__]
man I can't man you [__] man you're a
beast [__] what the [__] why the [__]
they not using you on the show baby
that's what he said to me that's good
advice yeah that's like I know people
misuse Zen but that is like them that's
like that was that's like real like if
you're comfortable and he is
if I used one word to describe David it
would become comfortable he's a
comfortable dude and everywhere he goes
he takes he makes it a party he brings
this subwoofer with him where he'll hook
up his Bluetooth he's got his own music
playing when he comes up he's like all
about partying Ambience and making
everything everything comfortable for
everybody really that's how he is wow
all right yeah just don't go to them
parties man just uh well I heard that I
don't want to call him sex parties but
I've heard if you're at Jamie Foxx's
house past 11 and you're wearing clothes
you're the weirdo
that's what somebody told me I don't
know I've never been I've never been
people listen when Pete Holmes has
you're going to be on some weird podcast
hey man Pete when you get comfortable
you don't be showing your dick and you
ain't gonna care about it just really
good just show it you ain't gonna care
about it you know why because you're
comfortable ain't you comfortable
[__] I'm very comfortable he's
that's very comfortable
Rock
you know what that sounded like that
sounded like Ryan Reynolds yeah my rock
hard nips
you're absolutely right if what am I
gonna do
drink a glass of diarrhea in front of
you it's always like something kind of
like real dirty it's like well just
spread my buck cheeks and fill it with
Nutella
oh Ryan what
what yeah yeah and you know what's funny
about Ryan Reynolds he's been doing that
like he's such a phenomenon now but if
you watch a Ryan Reynolds movie like one
of his early movies he was doing
Deadpool yeah he's been playing and
that's what names dropped that's what
Conan told me he's like just do what you
do and keep doing it and eventually let
them come to you and that's definitely
what Ryan Reynolds did yeah he wasn't
like figuring it out yeah you watch Ryan
Reynolds in like a very old Ryan
Reynolds movie he's doing the exact same
thing he's doing in Florida that part
was pretty much made for me nobody else
could play that guy exactly I'm the only
guy who can play Deadpool
no one can play Deadpool but me
because I'm Ryan [__] Reynolds so the
bullying when when did it stop and what
did it do to you
um well when did it stop man okay so
you're like I was bullied on the way
here I was like yo man yeah dude in the
car like [__] what Google bullied me
while I was on my way over here on the
Samsung it was like why don't you have
an iPhone
you still have green bubbles we're tired
of this you know yeah you do have a
green pillow I do that's all right but
it's I don't mind it the the game he had
some [__] to say about it I'm like
you've been shot at and you're worried
about my green bubbles the game was
texting with you and said why do you
have green bubbles yeah yeah and you're
like shouldn't you be counting every day
as a blessing
and you're worried about my green
bubbles you almost died
game
well I'm not going to say that because
what if it wasn't him
but some rapper one time I was with this
dude named Robbie I was having dinner
with Aaron Rodgers and rappers love
Aaron oh wow okay okay okay that's you
that's you this is my Den zone no okay
all right I wasn't even trying to do it
but you know now now since you want to
get into it okay yeah you wanna you
wanna talk to me you want to talk to me
like that always a little New York
yeah he's from Mount Vernon yeah oh
Mount Vernon yeah you ever get to yeah
yeah you know that place you know huh
you just put this wagon there okay yeah
yeah the Duck Sauce give me the duck
sauce
yeah yeah the Duck Sauce the duck sauce
on there yeah
if you would like uh it's not just the
voices you fi you mine it and you find
yeah yeah the Ducks I couldn't do it if
you gave me a 45 minute you can do it
you can do it you know you can do it
that's what he would say that's right
you can't tell yourself that you can't
do it Pete you can do anything you put
your [__] mind through your boys and
girls club Boys and Girls Club get up in
there boys get up in there even though
there's a lot of people who steal huh
yeah I got stolen from that's where the
bullying started huh that's real [__]
what did Denzel say to Will Smith
[Laughter]
it's amazing
because then they'll go up to will after
the slap yeah yeah yeah yeah so so I
approached will afterwards and I am
and I talked to him I said listen
I said
when you're at your high that's when the
double aims at you that's right that's
right
so you make sure you got to make sure
you do well too yeah you know it's like
you know it's like insane because you
know like I never thought that I never
thought I would like react like that you
know when you know because it happened
so spontaneously but
you know like like P you gotta
understand that you know um yeah
um I've been like pushed like constantly
like over the years and like the thing
with Chris was it was like you know he
said some things in 2016 and like you
know I really didn't like it and like
you know that was had I had nothing to
do nothing to do with Jada nothing at
all it was it was just totally me and
like I take full accountability and I
would also like to say again you know
that to Chris's mother you know like I'm
sorry for like you know smacking your
son and you know making him look like a
[__] on National Television yeah I mean
I mean like making them look soft no no
no I mean I mean I mean you know
attacking him
yeah
did y'all get that yeah check it out yes
totally awesome that is so good that's
good
mother is Will Smith again yeah yeah my
mother
what is going on it's just like you know
it's like the you know taking it and
like it's the movement of everything you
know just like the mouth you know the
the nose the ears like if he wants to
get back into social media he needs to
use me as PSAs and like you know deep
fake or have me talk for him because
everything is better in chocolate yeah
listen man like
you said
you just did for five minutes listen
listen man like you know I got smacked
so what like I'll talk about it it'll be
funny but whatever duh like
what can you do I got smacked by the
softest [__] in Hollywood
I got smacked by
the Suge Knight of kindergarten okay
like
you turned me into black church
like Def Jam like I have to like get up
you're so funny you have to like make it
physical like you're like get up move
around and stuff it's it's just too much
that's it that's it oh my God that was
great I I felt bad morning radioing you
but that yeah like I I just knew you
could do it it was so good not but the
good thing was that you were talking
about was um we were talking about
getting bullied that's what we were
talking about yeah yeah the Duck Sauce
but the Duck Sauce up there yeah the
duck swords that's what it is right only
Denzel could make sweet orange Chinese
sauce sound like yeah sounds sexy yeah
yeah that's why you sound real sexy huh
yeah Pete Holmes my man that's where he
is huh okay I'm glad you know what I got
I gotta say something about you Pinos
because
it was uh
you know you said this Joe and I thought
it was really funny you said um you
reference yourself like Val Kilmer and
you said um that was just so it was so
it was so funny to me because that the
first time I looked at you I was like yo
that looks good
you know you know he's eating less Gucci
and he looks good
you know that's what happened right huh
that's right he can't talk because he
kept eating the Box okay all right is
that how he got it well I don't know but
you know that hey
[Laughter]
I guess it was good you know you keep
returning hey sometimes you you know
what's up
um okay so when did it stop and what did
it do to you I I hate to go into the
cliche yeah but did it develop your
sense of humor did you did you try to
win these I started doing I started
doing impressions at six and that's when
I I yeah that's a way I felt like I
don't know I was just playing around
with it and I know girls liked it like I
had a I got a girlfriend at six and um
she liked it and I was like yo if your
girlfriend is sick yeah man I was in
here cooties never existed what
yeah I was in there man sick but she
also said she was 32. yeah she was yeah
she's 46. you so 72 was a nursing home I
was her character for me uh she bribed
me with butterscotch it was we're in the
Riff bubble it's okay we're in the rest
but you developed your humor so the
cliche is true you were under stress
yeah and it actually sort of pressurize
the the coal into a diamond I feel like
it yeah yeah I definitely feel like that
and I had you know I gained I gained so
much weight when I was six years old
really yeah man I was I turned to a
little fat kid I went to New York for
one summer and went to Fat Camp yeah
yeah I went to yeah I went to I went to
uh uh uh what's it uh Drake's um what's
it called Drake's BBW Camp that's where
I went BBW Camp big beautiful women big
beautiful women well those are all my
aunts they're all big beautiful
voluptuous women yeah and um they like
to cook fried chicken and I liked I
discovered it and I knew I I knew I were
you eating okay I was eating it a lot
they were feeding me can I say I ate to
calm down my anxiety too there's like a
after you after a big meal it's it's a
little bit like a drug like you're full
and you're just kind of like no problems
for a little while I was doing that I
just think it was it was something new
to me because I was I was like yo on
what is all I get to just have this all
the time like this is great like they my
aunt cooked for the church in New York
goddamn my lips getting
Savage again cracking crack that liquid
I can see you I can see you licking
yeah you mean queuing you to have it
yeah yeah that's what I thought yeah um
drink some water drink some water yeah
[Laughter]
um so I'm around them
um I guess my mom wanted us to be
coached a little more because you know
we suburb kids and everything went up
there
oh shoot I'm so sorry
he's talking I can project
I know how to project with addiction
Nathaniel is that you yes
just hi
Daniel
the 14th
everyone should get to hang out with you
for a couple hours it would just do it
would do wonders for National Healthcare
just feeling better he's the new Patch
Adams
this is the Negro Patch Adams that's
what he is he's the NPA baby the Negro
Patch Adams have you seen FBA yeah I got
a I got a mind I got a mind to do
something man I feel like I I just just
deviating a little bit from the topic
again as we've done continuously we
always get back to this yeah sure sure
the nucleus of everything
um I feel like I have a lot of the same
sensibilities as Robin Williams has is
that right I feel like I just all his
characters have like a certain innocence
you know damn we've been talking for
that long I all his characters in 90
minutes yeah that's crazy it was etchum
sketched on it was it was just drawing
up there it looked good it looked good
you know you dated as it by hand
um I feel like I feel like he has an
innocence in all of his characters you
can see it in his eyes I know what you
mean it's like a child like it's
vulnerability yeah since it's openness
yes absolutely
[Music]
yes he was like no he was rapping he he
wrapped Swiss beats uh song [__]
ridiculous to me and he was like [__]
ridiculous oh I was like yo you [__]
know that he was like I'm a soul brother
and he did that and just walked off and
then wow he screamed and I was like that
guy's crazy and I love it and Robert
Downey Jr gets in the elevator Robert
Downey you did the same thing I did yep
she she did the same thing same exact
thing that I did you know just totally
just you know just just came off real
weird bro just real weird you were
really weird and you know when somebody
gets really weird like that it's like
you know if you can bail or you can get
weird I decided to get weird you know so
you know just like you know he got weird
with you you're just you're a weirdo
you've been called weird ever since you
were six years old they've been calling
you weird
it's you yep where were you you were
just about to tell me okay okay I was um
I was okay this was I was in New York I
gained weight okay so okay so I was
about to tell you this I knew I had
gained a lot of weight because
before I had left for New York before
that Dreadful summer that came out where
all the fat cells expanded you gained
all your fat sales at five right don't
they say some [__] like that is that
true I think so something to do with
that um damn did I have a brownie why my
lips like this
yeah it is kind of like a stone sort of
feel you don't seem stoned at all but no
I'm not drinking water like a stone
Stoney baloney yeah it's well I drink a
lot of water anyway but you know I have
to I got you know my liver is uh it was
on the fritz it's better now um from
drink from yeah from yeah I'm jerking
off it was all every sin leads to it
every sin leaves the living and yes
leads to something but the jerking off
leaves to deliver worth it yeah so okay
so you got your fat cells at five fat
cells are fine you started eating your
aunties started eating my aunties
chicken and everything and and the New
York food oh my God the Chinese food oh
man we had for lunch every day I used to
eat like these um we have fried shrimp
and pork fried rice yeah oh my God yeah
right so good yeah it was so it was so
it I had never my mother didn't she
wasn't giving us all of that yeah so
when I got up there I just went ham you
know I mean literally I had ham as well
and
um I literally went ham we really went
really turned into the ham turned into a
whole fat ass ham came back I was taking
a I used to take showers of course you
got to take showers but when I would
take showers before I left from New York
the water would go straight down my back
yeah I came back I kept wondering why
the floor was getting wet and it was
shooting or I looked back and it was
shooting off like
a Mall fountain you know what I'm saying
like it was shooting oh you were
cascading yes you were you were like a
Mr Peanut shaped boy yes and it would
slide and and swallow them off your Off
Your Plum eye badonkadonk my donkey
and then you noticed you were getting
fat because the shower the water wasn't
it wasn't going straight down anymore I
was like God this is new this ain't wow
it wasn't like this before what happened
I looked back pass was like how you
doing I was like
[__] [__] [__]
and I had that problem I had this is so
this is that so going back to this this
is a big big insecurity I was [__]
with uh yo they used to pick on me hey
big butt they would call me all of that
um you know uh you know Fatso or as my
grandmother likes to put it husky you
know that yeah that's husky doesn't help
I'm not one of my dog yeah yeah husky
that's a nice way of saying you're fat
as [__] that's all it is Husky that's
all husky a husky kid section yeah get
the whole section thick thick well we
were taking it thick back yes we're
taking thick and honestly yeah you were
thick it was okay I had a I was I was
built like my Aunt it was crazy I was
built and then what did you do to your
like the if I was describing you to
somebody I'd be like you know he's a
he's a lowercase L he's a lowercase L
yeah okay yeah just uh yeah yeah just uh
yeah there we go no not in a bad way but
you're not uh but I don't know now I'm a
now you're alive here I'm a line now I'm
a line I actually was big from 6 to 17
so I was whoa I was picked on from I was
picked on from yeah from five got
bullied and then I was from six to damn
yeah until I was 17. that's a long time
it was a long time to be bullied and
then like
they were good they were good times too
I mean five years later you were on SNL
though five years later I was on SNL
[__] you
[__] you Indian River High School no no
I love them it's just the kids the you
know oh five [__] y'all oh one to o5 a
lot of y'all I don't [__] you know I
didn't [__] with you don't try to do a
guest list
all right see I'm talking see you on
this camera I'm on this I got you okay
so okay so I lost uh 75 pounds in three
and a half months my senior year and
graduated with honors it was I don't
know I went from a what did you do 2.45
to a 3.06 in a year I ran on a treadmill
every day 10 minutes uh level six and I
ate nothing but a small plate of
barbecue and
um a a salad with some oil some lemon
juice and some salt and if I I had my
fat Cravings I would chew the food up
and spit it out and I did that [__] for
three and a half four months and I lost
75 [__] pounds nobody know who knew
who the [__] I was uh at graduation but
uh but yeah but that does sound it
doesn't sound like the healthiest thing
in the world it was driven by fear
you're chewing things and spitting them
out it was but but Pete honestly man at
that point in my life I I went through
depression I was depressed for from like
12 to uh 12 to probably 12 to 17. when I
lost like five years yeah I was
depressed for five years so I looked in
the mirror and I said dude I I was plot
I was plot con I was contemplating
suicide and I said if if I don't change
this I'm going to hurt myself and I have
to get rid of this because this is
causing so much uh it's it's causing so
much sadness yeah yeah I was never the
confidence she had like a break yeah it
felt like I can't live with myself
anymore like this yeah I can't I can't
do this anymore and I don't and I don't
want to graduate with the average
diploma so I have to get honors I just
[__] man I want a road the Chesapeake
rotary scholarship for the most improved
GPA in Chesapeake it was really it's
[__] crazy which came first like
it's interesting when I think about like
exercise or eating right it's something
there has to be like a mental shift
first you know what I mean do you
remember what helped you get that shift
I I it sounds like maybe you already
gave me the answer it was like
desperation that's what it was yeah it
was it was do or die you know it was
literally do or die I mean I had started
stand up I'd started theater when I was
eight years old too as a theater kid
um so that that never helps your uh
never helps your your social setting in
school because everybody thinks theater
kids are weird yeah yeah a little weirdo
with their Fife so yeah yeah like we're
going around yeah bowling in there and
their accordions and things and but I
don't understand then they become the
people that everybody in our culture
worships isn't that crazy it's like Al
Pacino in high school was a dork
you know what I mean I didn't even know
that you know I'm just making sure yeah
okay okay I got you if you were a
theater guy you probably weren't
considered cool like the jocks were cool
right and little Al Pacino yep and then
uh
this liquid death it's real water is
killing me you see it's not supposed to
it's not right it's not natural it's
supposed to hydrate you this [__] every
time I take a sip it pulls it out if he
pulls it out man and it's like ah go
back to the good box into the defense it
is on the camp it yeah I'm saying that
to be or not to be some Hamlet [__] just
because I'm I'm so your story is
inspiring and I'm so glad
I I well I'm not glad for all of it it's
heartbreaking to think of a little boy a
little guy breaking like that yeah yeah
but I'm glad you went that way and so
that way yeah and got things together
and that's really beautiful I do just
because we're almost out of time as
Katie gave us that thing where are you
with faith now by the way we asked this
to everybody it's not just because we
talked about church earlier this is uh
now I feel like I'm getting back to uh
getting back to where I was
right before I got depressed and that's
when it was the strongest you know uh I
am uh I'm cleaning up I am not uh
cleaning up my life like you know I'm
not I don't drink as much anymore I
don't um was that advice yeah I think
yeah well that would that came that came
in my 20s just coping with a lot of [__]
you know what I mean just just having a
sip of a drink or whatever but but also
a lot got dumped on you so you're not
saying no I am saying it's
understandable a lot of comedians a lot
of people in these Lifestyles absolutely
need to shut off and they don't know how
to yeah so you started drinking a little
bit I started drinking you know me and
my uh you know me and my my
ex-girlfriend we would celebrate
whatever she had a kid too I was kind of
a stepdad at 22 to 26 there was and
being on SNL and the pressure of that
there's a lot of that going on and then
the whole diversity thing that happened
that I almost got clipped for that uh
that caused even though that was the
best year I had 19-14 was the best year
in SNL I felt like I had there's so much
good stuff that year
um and then the show the exit from the
show and all of that and then white Fame
is getting uh uh canceled after one
season when it for me all right yeah it
was it was fair dude you know it's like
it premiered the day after my birthday
and the day after Christmas they took it
away it was oh the day before Christmas
it was one of them days wow I just know
my lips are going again no no no no okay
that was just me okay cool I have never
signaled you once okay I'm just really
no I understand zero you're very uh
in tune yeah yeah you're not signaling
you okay cool cool
um um but that's why man a lot of that
came from that and by the time I
realized it uh how much I had done it
was the pandemic it's 20 20. wow because
I am so used to just sound like Robert
Downey you know I'm so used to powering
all the way through everything just
saying [__] it [__] it bro everything's
cool I'm just gonna run through it
nothing's gonna be everything's fine and
I don't deal with things and when you
don't do that you drink or me I was
drinking you know and you know when
you're on the road you're [__] doing
doing amazing you're killing on stage
people are giving [__] Innovations
you know you're getting [__] whatever
you just it's like okay this is life and
you don't have time to look at the
failures or the the mishaps or the
things that you need Improvement yeah
and you don't want to you don't want to
yeah and so I remember 2020 is just when
I really when I got to just stop and I
and I went home and I just want my mom
and I just hugged and I started crying
man because I was like yo I thought a
lot of [__] I've been dealing with you
know finally have a chance to think
about everything that's happened because
he even went dude even when I got the
call the call about SNL the end of it
and everything even when I got the call
everything was going because they hadn't
renewed my contract and I got white I
just got white famous and had just asked
them if they they were asking if I could
come in the first week and all of that
and still work you know she was like
yeah okay so I'll do double jobs and
then it's like oh no you go ahead and do
that and I'm like well okay [__] it and
then I got the producer call in she's
like you know she's tearful she's
teary-eyed I'm like listen just tell me
how y'all gonna do this I'm thinking I'm
not I'm not dealing with the emotional
aspect I'm dealing with the business
part of it and I you can't do that you
have to you got to give yourself time to
deal with the emotional part of anything
because if not it's this corrosive this
corrosive uh um growth inside of you
that just keeps expanding into this
black hole Yeah and hopefully you can
align yourself before it's too late and
you'll have anything left yeah like I'm
glad I got a chance to sit down and
realize what the [__] was going on you
know because I didn't and your faith
played into that definitely yeah and
then and now it's like I said it's
getting now it's I I'm aligning my I'm a
line in my life you know I I used to be
out here on these streets crazy not
doing that uh anymore have a you know
you still got people prospects I'm
looking for somebody to chill with and I
think that's all a part of me wanting to
a relationship relationship and drawing
closer to God because you know it ain't
it ain't right you're out here just
doing just
doing whatever yeah you're not supposed
to do that you know and it doesn't sit
right with people who do have a
spiritual
um a spiritual background that's right
there there is a obviously you can be
spiritual and not married and not have
kids for sure absolutely but there's a I
I'm with you that there's a corollary to
to me spirituality is about
self-sacrifice it's about not taking
yourself too seriously and not being the
center of the program so when I can
serve my wife and my daughter that feels
feels good the same as serving God or
serving a higher purpose they are the
manifestation of God in my life so like
making I've said this before but making
my daughter lunch or something I feel
like I'm making lunch for you know I'm
not saying my daughter's God I'm just
saying there's a loving gesture there's
a cleanness to it and she doesn't even
always thank me you know what I mean
because I'm not doing it for that and
that's a great feeling it is and you can
get the same thing it's it's love and
God is love so that's what that's right
feeling that you get that status that
satisfaction that gratification that you
get from from just uh you just it feels
good it's uh it's it's it comes from it
comes from above I agree and uh yeah and
there's something about our business
where we Trot our personality plays out
as our job and then you're rewarded for
it and I I'm not I wouldn't say it's
dangerous but it's good to back
counterbalance it with something that's
like yeah but what's the big picture you
and I happen to be alive in a time when
like what we do is valued but we can't
take our value just from that fact there
has to be something deeper I say to
myself every day I go God loves me
exactly the way I am and I find great
comfort in that but because it can't
just be
I am loved because I'm popular or right
because I got a standing ovation or
because I got a deal or because I'm
hanging out with Jay or whatever it is
because that stuff is yeah gone
yeah exactly so we have to have
something and do you have that you you
still uh obviously it sounds like you
believe in God absolutely and and I mean
my family is still my family is still
there uh to uh remind me and I
definitely draw close to them because
they're the I feel like they're the
closest my sister my mother my father
and my grandmother are the four closest
people to God that I know and when
anything I feel is off I always call and
I'll be like are y'all good and it could
be something going on with me that I I
don't know but they'll pull it out of
you but they'll pull it out yeah but you
knew you had the interesting to call
them yep Azhar Usman is a very funny
comedian he's he's a Muslim he told me a
prayer that I love he goes God give me
the faith of old women
and I was like I love that that's strong
right that's when you mention your
grandmother and all that sort of I'm
like yeah does it get any cleaner no
that's I always tell her to pray for me
because I'm like if you pray I know it's
gonna go up there that's right if other
people pray I knew what you know yeah
it's called my best friend one of them
hey man pray yeah yeah all right man
that ain't going nowhere he out here in
these streets
let me how much time what time is it
because unfortunately I have to go God
dang it oh [__] all right nope we'll go
a little I I just want to get get the
the questions I ask everybody out yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely you've been a
dream guest I'm so happy we got to do
this time together me too man yo Pete
there's I don't know if you feel this
dude but there's there's some I feel you
your characters in in my charactery I
feel like there's a world I couldn't
keep up with you I mean I'm honored if
this is going where I think it's going
I'm like that's a very big planet for me
to be able to satellite going I can do
albertino you know
like even past no not even not even just
yeah the voice I'm talking about just
your your character bro like the the
[__] that you would just oh thanks man
like the [__] the dude in the back of
the church with the hurt like brah I
could I can see that [__] I can see you
in the back of the [__] church I
could see me as the Reverend yeah I can
see all of it I could see that [__] bro
yeah we gotta figure it out yeah
definitely in fact there might be
something coming up we got man shooting
stuff is so expensive oh yeah we've been
trying to do these new Batman videos
we never financed them ourselves this is
boring it's almost over though and like
we're like okay we're just gonna front
the money ourselves it is prohibitively
expensive right like by the time you get
the budget and it's 20 000 more than you
thought it would be yeah and that was a
stretch yeah like to sit around and [__]
off and make some YouTube
it's like that's it I'm like geez but if
that goes forward there there's
something for us to do yeah for real
absolutely you would if you would do it
I would love to yeah all right well yeah
yeah I mean I got the joker as well yeah
I mean really yeah oh I used to do the
joker I'm not even going to try no
please I want to hear it absolutely I'm
like a dog chasing a car I wouldn't know
what to do if I got it
that's that's so good I want to know how
I got these cars yeah that's it see you
[__] you honing yeah yeah yeah you
know my father I hate I hated my father
look at me look at me that's it
you see this is what Batman has done to
Gotham nothing to do with all your power
nothing to do with all your strength
you've got nothing on me I'm gonna tell
you where they both are uh one's dad oh
my God God do you want to know which of
them are cowards
um man I so I know your friends more
than you do dad would you like to know
which one of them are cowards see you
went low with it which is what it was
yeah that's what it was this is that's
dope that's great come on that's great
Katie when I'm on my deathbed just send
clips of Jay being like that was good
my EKG says
he's alive
okay here are the questions have you
ever almost died
um have I ever almost oh yeah yeah I
guess so sort of they don't have to be
like a helicopter blade almost to get up
but tell me what you thought
um well when I got wrongfully detained
by the LAPD yes uh I I don't mean to be
excited about it no I was hoping you
would mention this because it seems yeah
yeah it should get out there that's real
like I had that app told me to walk
through that situation like two blocks
before those cops the app told me to
walk wait whatever I had an app called
the wrench called The Run Tracker app
and It's haunting because it doesn't
work it hasn't worked since that day
what is this app the um it's it's an app
that clocks your progress and um you
know keeps showing a schedule of running
oh okay so heart rate stuff yeah so just
like walk right right right and you
walked and out and I walked and you
matched the description I matched a
description of of a black man which is
where black man with sweatpants and a
sweatshirt yeah which is any black man
America
that's real talk yeah no it's a joke I
have it's fine I oh it is I always
thought it was a joke no but I mean it's
real everybody like yeah but yes but
it's a serious side to this that I
absolutely sound like I'm laughing and I
mean no no no no and you can't because
we all have to you have to find the pain
in the punches and I had to do that [__]
with that well yes I thought you were
saying every black man in America is
wearing a black I thought that was the
bet but what you're saying is
that could have been anybody that's the
that's the seriousness it could have
been any and you that's why I'm saying
you match description here quotes and
they and the LAPD was incredibly rough
with you yeah I mean they you know well
I've seen them do worse but it's uh you
know an innocent person you putting them
in handcuffs and putting your knee on
them and on the knee and the bottom of
the neck and all it's just uh
it's really uh it's really scary
especially what you know now well I'm
sure I'm shelter I was shelter bro like
and that the the first time I felt
racism was in Montreal the year before
and then that happened right there uh
that happened 2020 and um those like I
told you the app told me to slow down
I've said Slow Down walk and I'm
convinced that was God talking to me
because those couple of blocks when I
got over there and the helicopter flew
over my head I didn't know what the hell
was happening and I couldn't hear I got
my Bose headphones on bro you know what
I'm saying I got the the noise canceling
I can't hear anything I saw I turned and
happened to see the cop with his gun out
say freeze and get on the ground if I
hadn't seen that man through that
situation God forbid yeah and and and
then do when I was on the ground the app
goes run
that is
dark poetry right there that's star
poetry the app said run if I wouldn't
have heard him and I would have kept
going through that situation I would
have started and I started running
started running I didn't even started
that together yeah I thought the dark
poetry because you were in danger so I
was like run the app is like I don't
know about this but what you're saying
is if you listen to this app and started
running you would have looked
obviously that has not caused to shoot
anybody right but unfortunately in this
day and age right we've seen less right
if I hadn't seen that cop and I would
have kept my head straight and he was
yelling at me hey stop freeze freeze and
then the app would have been like run to
and I would have started this man
probably would have shot me and I
wouldn't have been here today so well
maybe I would have survived maybe I had
a [__] uh a 50 Cent Story or some
[__] I don't know yeah the [__] game
store you in Jamaica huh Jamaica Jamaica
Queens yes yes it's happened right the
South Side South Side is the do or die
that's what he says they think I'm grimy
I'm greasy but I'm making 187 look easy
that's what I do
you know Pete it's so crazy because
see it's crazy because it's like it's
like when you put in that situation
and you're somebody who like is used to
being from The Burbs and not the hood
it's that was it we just landed right in
the center of the bullseye
yeah uh-huh because you know and you're
from The Burbs and that happens to you
you know you start looking at you know
the white folks around you a little
differently you like yo you yeah I
thought you was cool you know like yeah
but you know because you know where I'm
from you know y'all was everybody was
cool from the birds you know watches
blacks everybody's making Barack Obamas
and Mariah Carey's up in here nobody
cares you know you feel me so impression
is so good I'm filled with the light and
also deep concerns that's why that's and
that's why I threw it that's where I
started because it is a dark it's
something dark to talk about well I'm
I'm sharing in the gratitude that that
didn't go another way me too man that is
that feels a seven month dude a a
premature baby seven months that came
out that wasn't supposed to survive and
and grew to be six foot two and this at
six years old people were bullying him
and calling him Jared the parrot he
somehow took that flipped it he used to
call me Jared the parrot and it wasn't
even because I could do Impressions
because it rhymed with my name wow Jared
Parrott I was like come on man what the
[__] well at least it's not Jared Fogle
but you know you know you know went
another way yeah it went another way
with it so um but from my name was biter
shaft I just want to join in
because apparently I give [__] but I
bite I don't know oh man I don't even
get it you bite the oh man biter shaft
oh I think I bite shafts you bite her
shaft I'm a biter shaft oh man that's oh
that's sharp that's uh now we're back to
Bill Bear yeah
why are you see why do you keep saying
that and uh can you tell me I'm sorry
I'm sorry I have to let me wrap that up
okay oh I'm going from that going that
kid who didn't who got bullied he
learned how to overcome his [__] to
losing weight to to [__] the cop [__]
there's a story that I'm supposed to
tell and obviously I'm here to still
tell it it has not been told yet well
maybe it started to be told and I'm just
in it and I don't realize it but I I
feel like I have a message that I'm
supposed to leave I have a big message
I'm gonna leave with this world and even
more I'm Gonna Keep leaving leaving
words of wisdom whatever and I'm
supposed to help people in some way and
then making them forget about this [__]
you know and uh I'm gonna do that it's
my mission yeah yeah that's my that's my
mission that's what I'm supposed to do
what's your problem absolutely that's my
mission this is now Chevelle this is now
Chappelle because you
because you ruined my [__] life that
that I do drink now because you ruin my
[__] life that's it
am I canceled or am I not canceled
that's the question
let me know
wow and then
when you tell me that I'm canceled I'll
say suck my dick
that is that was it if you even invoke
like you had the intensity I was sort of
like oh man it was like an intensity to
it that was great that I feel when I
watch them too that was great wow hey
man can you this is the last question
okay
um did you get all of them I want to
make sure I got add it's not diagnosed
because my mother didn't let this I got
a black mom she didn't let the system do
it but go ahead
say it say it I would say say it say it
I want you to say it say riddling
and everybody was like all the white
people like no okay your dad your dad's
taking his fans up you're gonna see the
jingle jangle I'm coming at you like fat
Ryan
okay I'm a medical doctor you're you're
fat Ryan now
his own deck
um look who hasn't been slapped by their
own decks while jogging
slap I mean when I run
the whole room get dark
that's birdie that's Bernie Mac that's
Bernie Mac I take it out the whole room
get dark when I pull this look I'm I'm
hung low I'm gonna have instruction I'm
blessed you know and I'm blessed he said
I'm blessed you know can't do [__] no
more and I'm blessed I'm hung low I'm
heavy structure I pull my [__] out of
this whole room get Black Chaos
chills this is one of my favorite sets
of all time and you brought me back to
it I watched that when I'm feeling
disillusioned about stand up and like
really you're like oh don't forget don't
forget it can be incredible sometimes
can you tell me the time in your life
you laughed
so hard you were crying and you hurt
tell me uh
multiple times it happened on this
podcast
yes we laughed today what the [__] you
did oh yes the [__] sprinkler the
[__]
wait what the oscillating sprinkler
that's it but I'm saying it's happened I
love I love laughing because you know my
my parents are [__] her my dad is the
funniest one of the funniest human
beings my mother's one of the funniest
people in the world my dad though he's
like he will have you falling out your
chair crying laughing wow and I'm
telling you the [__] that he says is so
obscure and off but it's it makes
perfect sense and um okay so this is
what happened and we were just watching
this is just him watching somebody
sometimes he predicts the future it's so
[__] crazy and if it happens
perfectly in front of your eyes you're
just like you were [__] right and
it's so funny okay
we're at the church convention bring it
right back to church what a call back
right to church church convention right
all right me and my dad were upstairs in
the hotel room right uh he tells me but
what we're watching downstairs we see
this little fat kid named his name is
Bernard he's you know he's a little he's
sister Maxine's son oh man I don't know
how I don't know how he looks now but
okay he's Bernard Bernard used to be
Bernard was a little chunky boy
and he's
so he the the fountain is right beside
him right
and the rail is right here he's sliding
he's sliding down the rail like he's
Tony Hawk that's when like Pro Skater
was hot he keeps sliding down the hole
my dad is watching my dad says this Pete
but man he goes that little [__] gonna
mess up
he's a new little [__] messed up on
supervised he said you watch he gonna
mess up and he kept saying that and I
was like what do you mean he ain't gonna
he ain't gonna mess up he gonna mess up
watch he watch he gonna it was ominous
as [__] right pretty hard Bernard's
gonna [__] up you're not gonna mess up
he goes my dad tells me it's getting
late now he's like go get your sister go
tell her to come up it's time it's time
to go to sleep or whatever we got church
in the morning
I said okay I'm going down in the
elevator mind you the elevators he's got
a clear view clear glass you can see
everything going down Bernard's down
here this is this is it it's coming we
got it we got a software on a skateboard
we gotta we got a truth telling Dad
Bernard Bernard's right here he's
sliding down the pole again
somehow he flips over the pole and all
you hear is
he fell in the [__] fountain
yo I had a
I had a front seat yeah you had a you
had like a balcony seat coming down get
a moving balcony in the [__] water yo
I said
I got Yo I looked upstairs my dad was
all about me like this
I could tell he was laughing I go
downstairs I'd go downstairs and get my
assistant but I walked past Bernard and
I'm looking at him he just gets up he
goes
oh he starts crying I'm laughing my ass
off the the the the the lady that's
trying to help him she's like it's not
funny I said you're right it's funny as
[__]
yo okay not all bad Bernard got like 75
cents in Chains he did picking it up on
his way out no he'll win here there's a
win he had 2.74 cents and change somehow
he's bigger understand that she can
carry pockets of giants his pockets are
big you know they're really heavy you
know they're like really and the
fountain was you as a child but thick
with the water cats getting off your
butt ah so I get my sister I tell her I
was like your dad did tell him say
you're shady did you just see what
happened
just like she's like yo she was like I
was watching I was kind of watching them
she said did he fall in the water I said
he fell in the water and she
I go upstairs I go back in the elevator
I'm Bernard's trying to wipe himself off
and [__] right his mom at this point
she's downstairs she gets him
I go back up to the room my dad looks at
me he's laughing like this he go I told
you that little [__] was gonna mess up
he's on the floor kicking his feet oh my
God that [__] mate oh my gosh I died God
bless you Bernard wherever you are but
bless you but that was so [__] you
you gotta laugh at this now bro that's
your gift you know he's got to be like
22 now with 23 or something bro it's you
you you you fell in the water
Jesus that was a great one oh I love
this when is it dude when is this coming
out bro oh you know it might it might be
not this Wednesday but maybe a week from
Wednesday oh okay yeah unless there's a
time that's better for you I mean if you
could put it on Wednesday I would love
it but uh well they need time to edit it
okay the cameras all right well that's
this will be a good nugget man this is a
good when I say good nugget I mean like
a good a good show that's like
everything was just fun bro buddy
you know we've been doing how many
episodes
600. Jesus crime so there's like a
certain point where you're like
you just pray for a Jay Pharoah
thank you for answering my prayers thank
you let's pick somebody you haven't done
because we have the guests say keep it
crispy yeah that's how we end the only
one because I wrote down some of my
favorites you didn't do Kevin Hart we
end the show with the guest saying keep
it crispy would you say keep it crispy
as Kevin Hart absolutely if you want me
to whatever whatever you need all right
we've done some new ones today I got you
got some new Impressions up here I've
never done Robert Downey Jr anybody so
good it's ready to go that was Iron Man
3. not Iron Man 2. that was real good
that was real good the current it was
current yes so Kevin Hart saying keep it
crispy however you want listen uh
listen love this guy love this guy first
of all uh wow uh you're amazing gotta
say that why do I have to say that
because I have to give you your flowers
uh a lot of people uh they don't give
folks flowers what we do is uh we thank
flowers and then by the time we're ready
to give them folks aren't here to
receive them so I'm gonna give you your
flowers you're absolutely amazing first
of all ah hey what's going on this is uh
it's Kevin Hart and uh just uh just
keeping it crispy that's what it is
that's not what I'm supposed to say what
am I that was it that was it oh oh you
did say ink just say keep it crispy okay
ah listen sorry gotta rewind
wow ah listen it's Kevin Hart uh keep it
crispy all day
that's what that's wrong no that was it
okay cool I'll make sure I knew it was
right I was just asking you because I
wanted to hear it because I like to hear
people give me uh what is it called
um love that's what I got flowers back
at you James thank you brother that was
good you are
your talent thank you you're made of
talent thank you thank you and charm and
heart thank you for all of that thank
you so much y'all yeah thank you so much
um really appreciate being up here y'all
this is you know this is y'all it's um
y'all it's definitely it's just the
Lauren just the maker of you know
creating televisions you know just Oh
Canada God I was gonna ask you to do
Lord and then yeah did it like
telepathically yeah yeah you know it's
um it's that thing where you know it's
the the end of the podcast you know
keeping it you know keeping it crispy
I thought for a second it was Alan
Rickman yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah
Alan Rick go ahead created S and L again
Jeremy Mitchell you know I thought you
would you know why when you said Alan
you said Alan Rickman I thought you
meant I thought you meant Alan uh what's
the other Allen Allen Alder Canada and
then I can't do Alan Alda as good as
hater but I can do it's it's almost like
I'm doing um Howard Stern
because Howard Stern has that thing
where he's like right yeah he just he
has this thing in the back of his throat
where he talks and he's just like wow
are those breasts or those
others yeah but there's water balloons
yeah like come over here sweetheart come
over here so creepy
so creepy shout out to him he's a cool
he's a nice dude why did I do that face
man I didn't do that
all right there we go all right
we're out thank you Jay thank you
[Music]